This episode is presented by Macy's. Shop now at macy's.com slash gift guide. One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night. I love the privacy of it and also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group.
本集由梅西百货（Macy's）赞助播出。现在就去 macys.com/giftguide 选购吧。我和家人最喜欢做的事情之一就是公路旅行。我们是公路旅行爱好者。乔什和我喜欢收拾好车子，带着孩子们出发。我非常喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。我们很喜欢用 Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里，喜欢有厨房，有后院或露台，晚上可以坐在那里。我喜欢它的私密性，而且即使你在冒险，也会感觉像在家里一样，因为你可以创造属于自己的家。你知道，Airbnb 对家庭来说真的很棒，因为你可以真正选择一个适合你们整个团体的住处。
You know, we did that one year with my family. We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure.
你知道，有一年我和家人就是这样做的。我们都在山里集合，选了一个很棒的 Airbnb，大家住在一起。表亲、侄女、侄子、阿姨和叔叔们。那真的太有趣了，而且非常温馨。Airbnb 确实让那次家庭记忆变得特别。所以，下次冒险就用 Airbnb 吧。
Hello everyone and welcome to your second drink of email surveillance. In our breakdown this week we have a fantastic interview with Ken Jeong. With a pop in from Joel McHale. Yeah these were the old days when a bunch of us were all recording at the same time. Yes and then we'd see people going from one podcast to another. It was a lot of fun. Well, in this episode, Email Surveillance, we get to see Michael Scott go to his improv class. Oh, it's so delicious. So good. And you know, when he's in improv class, he turns every scene into a Michael Scarn moment.
大家好，欢迎收听你们的第二杯“邮件监控”。在本周的解析中，我们有一段与郑肯（Ken Jeong）的精彩采访。乔尔·麦克哈尔（Joel McHale）还中途插了一脚。是的，那是我们很多人同时录音的旧时光。没错，然后我们会看到人们从一个播客转到另一个播客。那真的很有趣。好了，在这一集《邮件监控》中，我们看到迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）去上即兴表演课。哦，太精彩了。太棒了。而且你知道，当他在即兴表演课上时，他会把每一个场景都变成迈克尔·斯卡恩（Michael Scarn）的时刻。
He pulls out his imaginary gun and he shoots them. Well, in his interview, Ken Jeong shared some really fun stuff about shooting all those scenes. But I found an interview that Steve did with Janelle Riley for the Screen Actors Foundation where he explained the inspiration for Michael's character always pulling a gun in improv class. It was based on a real person.
他掏出他那把想象中的枪，然后把他们都射杀了。嗯，在采访中，郑肯分享了一些关于拍摄这些场景的趣事。但我发现史蒂夫（Steve）曾接受过简内尔·莱利（Janelle Riley）为美国演员工会基金会（Screen Actors Foundation）做的采访，他在采访中解释了迈克尔的角色在即兴表演课上总是掏枪的灵感来源。这是基于一个真实的人。
Yes. Let's listen. I know in the office, Michael Scott was a big fan of improv. His improvs were angry, but he was always pulling a gun. That's actually, that's based on a friend of mine. Oh, is it really? There was a guy at Second City who always used to pull a gun during scenes. And he knows it, and he'll laugh about it too.
是的。让我们听听。我知道在《办公室》里，迈克尔·斯科特是即兴表演的忠实粉丝。他的即兴表演很愤怒，但他总是掏枪。那其实是基于我的一个朋友。哦，真的吗？在第二城市（Second City）剧团有个家伙，他在表演场景时总是掏枪。他自己也知道，而且他也会拿这件事开玩笑。
But we actually let him, a scene got into the show at Second City, because we all agreed we're going to let Ron pull the gun, and then we're going to let him kill all of us in the scene. And that's what the scene was. That really made me laugh. It took me back to my improv days. Well, if you're like me and you wanted more scenes from that improv class, there are a lot more in deleted scenes.
但我们确实让他这么做了，有一个场景被放进了第二城市的演出里，因为我们都同意让罗恩（Ron）掏枪，然后我们要在场景里让他把我们所有人都杀掉。这就是那个场景的内容。那真的让我大笑。它把我带回了我的即兴表演时代。嗯，如果你像我一样，想要更多那个即兴表演课的场景，删除片段里还有很多。
Let's hear some. I need to know who shot Johnson. President Johnson. Let's hear some. I don't want to hear anything more from you. Now listen to what she's saying. Huh. All right, I'll be quiet if we can make some kind of deal. A deal? Blah, blah, blah, blah. No deals. Not with Michael Scarn, FBI. Michael Scarn doesn't make deals. Michael Scarn shoots and then asks questions later.
让我们听听一些。我需要知道是谁射杀了约翰逊。约翰逊总统。让我们听听一些。我不想再听你说任何话了。现在听听她在说什么。哈。好吧，如果我们能达成某种协议，我就安静下来。协议？巴拉巴拉巴拉。没有协议。迈克尔·斯卡恩，FBI，不谈协议。迈克尔·斯卡恩先开枪，然后再问问题。
Whew. Good. Good. Good. Guess what? Michael Skarn is now alone on stage because he no longer has any scene partners. I rewatched all these deleted scenes too and after that moment,
呼。好。好。好。猜猜怎么着？迈克尔·斯卡恩现在独自在舞台上，因为他不再有任何搭档了。我也重温了所有这些删除片段，在那一刻之后，
he gets in this whole argument with the teacher and the student about how she wasn't doing the scene right. The teacher's trying to like gently suggest that that could have gone another way. Right. And Michael's like, well, it could have gone another way if we wanted to do it not funny, basically, like that's his whole thing. He's like such a horrible scene partner. Well, there is another deleted scene which they actually added to the super fan
他和老师以及学生吵了起来，因为她没有把场景演对。老师试图温和地建议说，那个场景本来可以有另一种演法。没错，迈克尔说，如果我们想演得不那么好笑，那确实可以有另一种演法，基本上，这就是他的风格。他真是个糟糕的搭档。嗯，还有另一个删除片段，他们实际上把它加到了超级粉丝版里，
episode where the teacher tells everyone to partner up but no one wants to partner with Michael. No. He just can't. Why would they? No. So he just keeps shouting out suggestions and then the teacher keeps suggesting, you know what, why don't you take a break? It's really funny. All of these scenes, you know, brought me back to my improv days. I mean, I feel like I've shared with you how we had one guy who would steamroll every scene he was in, so we all just made a pact that in every scene we'd find a way to kill him. Oh, you were Michael Scarnin' him.
老师让大家找搭档，但没人想和迈克尔搭档。不。他就是不行。他们为什么要和他搭档？不。所以他一直大声喊出建议，然后老师一直建议说，你知道吗，你为什么不休息一下？这真的很有趣。所有这些场景，你知道，把我带回了我的即兴表演时代。我的意思是，我觉得我已经和你们分享过我们有一个家伙，他会碾压他参与的每一个场景，所以我们都达成了一个协议，在每个场景里我们都要想办法杀了他。哦，你们在“迈克尔·斯卡恩”他。
In reverse. Yeah. But you would, everyone got so creative, there were blow darts. There were attack of a killer cat. Well, you know, this is also the episode where Jim is throwing a party at his house and Michael finds out that he's not invited.
反过来。是的。但是你们会，每个人都变得很有创意，有吹箭。有杀手猫的袭击。嗯，你知道，这一集也是吉姆（Jim）在他家举办派对，而迈克尔发现他没有被邀请。
I know, there's actually a lot of discussion about who is invited and who is going. And Angela, in our breakdown, you mentioned how at five minutes and 57 seconds, we see the invite on Michael's computer. We see the invitation. Well, a new catch. I have a new catch. If you look closely, you can see that the Evite says 14 people have said yes to the Evite and two have not replied. and two have not replied. Now, we can only see who said yes,
我知道，关于谁被邀请了，谁要去，其实有很多讨论。安吉拉（Angela），在我们的解析中，你提到在5分57秒时，我们在迈克尔的电脑上看到了邀请函。我们看到了邀请函。嗯，有一个新发现。我有一个新发现。如果你仔细看，你可以看到电子邀请函上显示有14个人回复了“是”，有两个人没有回复。有两个人没有回复。现在，我们只能看到谁说了“是”，
but Pam is not on the list. Has she not replied? Maybe, but Pam has not confirmed her attendance. Well, lady, I found another nugget that might explain why Pam hasn't RSVP'd yet. I wonder if it's because she didn't know she was RSVPing for one or two people. When we broke down this episode,
但帕姆（Pam）不在名单上。她还没回复吗？也许吧，但帕姆还没有确认出席。嗯，女士，我发现了另一个可能解释为什么帕姆还没回复的小细节。我怀疑是因为她不知道她是代表一个人还是两个人回复。当我们解析这一集时，
we were speculating why Roy wasn't at Jim's barbecue. Well, the reason Roy doesn't go is a deleted scene, and it was added to the superfan episode. It's great. Let's hear it. Can you hear my stomach? Hi. Hey, babe, hey. Hey. How are you? Good. Hey babe, hey. Hey.
我们一直在推测为什么罗伊（Roy）没有参加吉姆的烧烤派对。嗯，罗伊没去的原因是一个删除片段，它被加到了超级粉丝版里。太棒了。让我们听听。你能听到我的肚子叫吗？嗨。嘿，宝贝，嘿。嘿。你好吗？好。嘿，宝贝，嘿。嘿。
How are you? Good. You look good. Thank you. Hey, um, I was wondering if it might be okay if I go to Lonnie's poker game tonight. I promise it'll be like the last time for a while. We're supposed to go to the barbecue at Jim's house. Oh man, um, could you go without me?
你好吗？好。你看上去不错。谢谢。嘿，嗯，我在想如果我今晚去朗尼（Lonnie）的扑克局可以吗？我保证这会是近期最后一次了。我们本来应该去吉姆家的烧烤派对的。哦天哪，嗯，你能不带我一起去吗？
Make something up, Sam. Ate something or... Huh? Huh? You're the best. You're the best. I might be late. Okay, don't wake me up because I'm playing ball in the morning. Okay. All right. Bye. I mean, he starts by telling her she looks great. Did you hear that? Yeah.
编个理由，萨姆（Sam）。吃坏东西了或者……哈？哈？你最好了。你最好了。我可能会晚点回来。好的，别叫醒我，因为我早上要打球。好的。好的。再见。我的意思是，他一开始就告诉她她看起来很棒。你听到了吗？是的。
He like butters her up before he ditches her for the night. Then says you're the best. Also don't wake me up. Yeah. I mean, he has to play ball in the morning. He's busy. He's got a lot going on. And none of it is with Pam. None of it. Well, everyone, that is your second drink for today.
他在抛弃她过夜之前先给她灌迷魂汤。然后说你最好了。还有别叫醒我。是的。我的意思是，他早上要打球。他很忙。他有很多事要做。而且没有一件事是和帕姆有关的。一件都没有。好了，各位，这就是你们今天的第二杯。
And now here is Email Surveillance. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies.
现在是《邮件监控》。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。
Welcome everybody to the email surveillance episode of Office Ladies. Howdy! It is season two episode nine written by Jen Salata, directed by Paul Feig, and we have a special guest in the studio with us today. He played Bill, one of the members of Michael Scott's improv class. It is our friend, Ken Jeong! Hey guys! Thank you so much for having me. We are so excited for having me.
欢迎大家来到《办公室女士》的《邮件监控》这一集。大家好！这是第二季第九集，由简·萨拉塔（Jen Salata）编剧，保罗·费格（Paul Feig）导演，今天我们演播室里有一位特别嘉宾。他饰演了比尔（Bill），迈克尔·斯科特即兴表演课的成员之一。他就是我们的朋友，郑肯！嘿，伙计们！非常感谢你们邀请我。我们非常兴奋……邀请我。
We are so excited you are here. You are our second in studio guest. Yes! You and Creed Bratton, Ken. That is privileged company, so I'm very, very excited to be here. So seriously, thank you guys and congrats, congrats on the success of your podcast. I listened to it and it's awesome. So thank you for having me.
我们非常兴奋你能来。你是我们的第二位演播室嘉宾。是的！你和克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton），肯。那是很有地位的伙伴，所以我非常非常高兴能来到这里。所以说真的，谢谢你们，恭喜你们，恭喜你们的播客取得成功。我听了，太棒了。所以谢谢你们邀请我。
Thanks, Ken. And this is Ken's day off. And I mean, you're a busy, busy person. I can't even get into the Masked Singer and what it means to my children and how much we have to talk about it. That's a whole nother subject, but you're a busy guy and we appreciate you coming in on your day off. Oh no, thank you.
谢谢，肯。今天是肯的休息日。我的意思是，你是一个非常非常忙的人。我甚至无法谈论《蒙面歌王》（The Masked Singer）以及它对我孩子们意味着什么，以及我们必须谈论它多少次。那是另一个话题了，但你是个大忙人，我们很感激你在休息日过来。哦不，谢谢你们。
Before we get into this episode, you two have known each other for a very long time. When did you guys become friends? You did a movie together. I think really Ken, what crystallized our friendship was your 40th birthday. Was it your 40th birthday? It was my 40th birthday.
在我们进入这一集之前，你们俩认识很久了。你们是什么时候成为朋友的？你们一起拍过电影。我想肯，真正让我们的友谊结晶的是你的40岁生日。是你的40岁生日吗？那是我的40岁生日。
Your 40th birthday. Okay, so he's twisting in his chair. He literally is about to fall off of his chair. I don't know this story. Okay, so, you know, Ken had done the office, but we didn't work together that day. Our paths never crossed. And then years later, we're on hiatus from The Office
你的40岁生日。好吧，所以他在椅子上扭来扭去。他简直快要从椅子上掉下来了。我不知道这个故事。好吧，你知道，肯演过《办公室》，但那天我们没在一起工作。我们的路径从未交集。然后几年后，我们从《办公室》休假，
and I am gonna be playing this role on a movie called Furry Vengeance. Brooke Shields was in it, Brendan Fraser. I'm such a huge Brendan Fraser fan. Oh my gosh, we were filming in the middle of nowhere, Massachusetts, day one. I think we were like two doors apart on our floor. Yeah, I know, we were on the same floor.
我要在一部叫《毛茸茸的复仇》（Furry Vengeance）的电影里演一个角色。布鲁克·雪德丝（Brooke Shields）在里面，还有布兰登·费舍（Brendan Fraser）。我是布兰登·费舍的超级粉丝。哦天哪，我们在马萨诸塞州荒郊野外拍摄，第一天。我想我们在那一层楼只隔了两个房间。是的，我知道，我们在同一层楼。
I think we were across from each other. We were across the hall, we were across the hall at the Radisson. Oh my gosh, this is so cute. I come out of my room, Ken comes out and I'm like, hey, you picked the Radisson too. We're like that. We're the only two actors that were.
我想我们在彼此对面。我们在走廊对面，我们在雷迪森酒店（Radisson）的走廊对面。哦天哪，这太可爱了。我走出房间，肯走出来，我说，嘿，你也选了雷迪森。我们就像那样。我们是仅有的两个……
Yeah, we're the only two actors in the Radisson with the crew. So we just would hang out all the time. We were always in the shuttle together. We became pretty fast friends right away. And that first week was Ken's 40th birthday. And here he is away from his family. You're a little sad about it.
是的，我们是雷迪森酒店里仅有的两个演员，和剧组在一起。所以我们总是待在一起。我们总是在同一辆班车上。我们很快就成了好朋友。第一周就是肯的40岁生日。他远离家人。你当时有点难过。
And we didn't have a car because we were on location. We had the day off. Our day off happened to be his birthday together, him and I. I said, you know what? I'm gonna take you out for your birthday. And from the Radisson, there was a, we were sort of up on a hill and you could see down the hill,
而且我们没有车，因为我们在外景地。我们那天休息。我们的休息日正好是他的生日，他和我的。我说，你知道吗？我要带你去过生日。从雷迪森酒店出来，有一个，我们当时在山上，你可以看到山下，
down a big steep hill in this parking lot was a PF Changs. And I said, I said, Ken, I'm taking you PF Changs for your birthday. Amazing. Not, wait, I don't know why we didn't wanna get a cab, but we- I know why. Why, why? You walked it?
沿着一个陡峭的大山坡，在停车场里有一家 PF Changs。我说，我说，肯，我要带你去 PF Changs 过生日。太棒了。不，等等，我不知道为什么我们不想打车，但我们……我知道为什么。为什么，为什么？你们走过去的？
We walked it, and it wasn't like it was connected into the parking lot. At one point we had to like crawl a little bit through a grassy median thing. Remember? It was like the parking lot was separated by like a little bit of a grassy knoll. Anyway, we walked down this parking lot. We go into P.F. Chang's at like 11 a.m. There's no- There's like no one there. We're the first people there.
我们走过去的，而且它不像是有路连通到停车场。有一次我们不得不像爬行一样穿过一片草地隔离带。记得吗？停车场被一个小草丘隔开了。总之，我们走过那个停车场。我们在上午11点左右走进 PF Changs。那里没有……那里几乎没人。我们是第一批客人。
We ate so much and drank a ton of beer and we were both really buzzed. And now we have to walk up this hill and we're like tipsy and we're like, oh my God, this hill sucks on the way back. And Ken was like, what did you do to me? My 40th birthday. Okay, you just decided mid-walk like, hey, I should just exercise. And you're like walking around the parking lot like you're doing laps. I said, pump your arms, Ken.
我们吃了很多，喝了一吨啤酒，我们俩都喝高了。现在我们得爬上这座山，我们醉醺醺的，我们说，哦天哪，回来的路上这座山太烂了。肯说，你对我做了什么？我的40岁生日。好吧，你只是在走路中间决定说，嘿，我应该锻炼一下。然后你就像在做圈数一样在停车场走来走去。我说，摆动你的手臂，肯。
And then you were literally speed walking drunk at a Radisson parking lot. Just remember, you're just, there's a hill. I was like, hey, pump your arms. Come on, pump your arms. Pump your arms. And I was just crying laughing. You were crying laughing so hard. You were like, what are we doing? And you turned to me.
然后你就在雷迪森停车场醉醺醺地竞走。只要记住，你只是，有一座山。我说，嘿，摆动你的手臂。来吧，摆动你的手臂。摆动你的手臂。我当时笑得眼泪都出来了。你笑得太厉害了，眼泪都出来了。你说，我们在做什么？然后你转向我。
Pump, pump, pump. Okay, okay, I've taken us off topic. All right, focus. Jenna, how about a summary? In this episode, Michael gains access to everyone's emails and discovers that Jim is hosting a barbecue. Everyone except Michael has been invited. Michael fumes, but Jim holds firm. After attending his weekly improvisation class, Michael crashes the barbecue after all, and
摆动，摆动，摆动。好吧，好吧，我把话题扯远了。好了，集中注意力。珍娜，总结一下？在这一集中，迈克尔获得了所有人的电子邮件访问权限，并发现吉姆正在举办烧烤派对。除了迈克尔，所有人都被邀请了。迈克尔怒火中烧，但吉姆立场坚定。在参加完每周的即兴表演课后，迈克尔还是闯入了烧烤派对，并且
Pam suspects Dwight and Angela might be a couple. Dun, dun, dun. Yes, this is a big episode. This is a big episode. All right, fast fact number one. We always start with fast facts, Ken. Well, Jenna loves a fast fact. Okay. Okay. So don't mess with them.
帕姆怀疑德怀特（Dwight）和安吉拉可能是一对。当，当，当。是的，这是一集大戏。这是一集大戏。好了，速记事实第一条。我们总是从速记事实开始，肯。嗯，珍娜喜欢速记事实。好的。好的。所以别搞砸了。
You like my fast facts. I like them too, but it's like you coined the phrase fast fact. Did I not? Joe McCall's flipping you off bad Joel. Do our listeners need some content bad Joel. This is Joe McCall my nemesis So we are in one recording booth and the glass window is racing his we can see him through the glass He can see us and he is being offensive, and aggressive.
你喜欢我的速记事实。我也喜欢，但就像是你创造了“速记事实”这个词。不是吗？乔尔·麦克哈尔在对你竖中指，坏乔尔。我们的听众需要一些内容吗，坏乔尔。这是乔尔·麦克哈尔，我的克星。所以我们在一个录音棚里，玻璃窗正对着他的，我们可以透过玻璃看到他。他能看到我们，而且他表现得很有攻击性，很有侵略性。
He gave us the bird, and then he mooned us. Now he's coming in. No, lock it. I am here with friends, alright? I'm here with people who I love and adore. Guys, my favorite Parks and Rec episode This is the office, Joel. No, this is the office, Joel. This is not.
他给我们竖了中指，然后他向我们露了屁股。现在他进来了。不，锁上。我和朋友在一起，好吗？我和我爱和崇拜的人在一起。伙计们，我最喜欢的《公园与游憩》（Parks and Rec）剧集……这是《办公室》，乔尔。不，这是《办公室》，乔尔。这不是。
No, this is the office. How dare you? This is the show that started it all. And as much as Angela and Jenna are best friends, you and I, if we had a show, we would call ourselves community enemies because I didn't like you, I never liked you for six seasons.
不，这是《办公室》。你怎么敢？这是开启这一切的剧集。尽管安吉拉和珍娜是最好的朋友，但你和我，如果我们有一个节目，我们会称自己为“社区敌人”（Community Enemies），因为我不喜欢你，我六季以来从来没喜欢过你。
I was over 100 episodes. We barely tolerated each other and the antipathy has only grown in the last four years. That is true and here's the thing. When we saved Ken's career. Stop talking about saving my career. Stop it. Have you ever listened? Stop it. Has he talked about how many? Just knock it off. When you look at his filmography, Stop it. Hangover, stop it. Hangover 2.
我拍了100多集。我们几乎无法忍受对方，这种反感在过去四年里只增不减。那是真的，事情是这样的。当我们拯救了肯的职业生涯时。别再谈论拯救我的职业生涯了。停下。你听过吗？停下。他谈过多少次？别说了。当你看看他的作品集，停下。《宿醉》，停下。《宿醉2》。
How dare you? Hangover 3. How about, I'm sorry but you're leaving furry vengeance. That's a movie Angela and I did together right before Community. I can't believe you're saying this on mic. Look, I'm here as a Humble Day player talking about how I was Bill on email surveillance. I want to go on record and say I really think Community Enemies is a great podcast. That just happened.
你怎么敢？《宿醉3》。还有，对不起，你要离开《毛茸茸的复仇》了。那是安吉拉和我一起拍的电影，就在《社区大学》（Community）之前。我不敢相信你在麦克风前说这个。听着，我作为一个卑微的临时演员，谈论我是如何在《邮件监控》里演比尔的。我想记录在案，说我真的认为《社区敌人》是一个很棒的播客。刚才发生了什么。
Will you please do a rewatch of Community with Joel and call it Community Enemies. And just give each other s** for like an hour. Speaking of, I'm a really big fan of Community and I remember that we would meet up at all the NBC events because we were on air at the same time and you had such a funny group of people and I loved the show and I would be interested in hearing some behind the scenes banter about that. Yeah, no, it was huge because I think the premiere, I think the first two episodes, I think we followed The Office just to survive on the air
你愿意和乔尔一起重温《社区大学》并称之为《社区敌人》吗？然后互相吐槽一个小时。说到这个，我是《社区大学》的超级粉丝，我记得我们在所有 NBC 的活动上都会见面，因为我们当时同时在播出，你们有一群非常有趣的人，我喜欢这个节目，我很想听听关于那里的幕后趣事。是的，不，那太大了，因为我觉得首播，我觉得前两集，我觉得我们紧随《办公室》之后才得以在 NBC 播出，因为我的意思是，《办公室》，你知道，周四晚上的 NBC 是旗舰节目，所以当我们发现它会在《办公室》之后播出时，我们总是，你知道，那是我们的支柱。而且很有趣的是，你认为某些节目，比如《办公室》，帮助了其他节目。然后，你知道，播出，留在电视上，然后给像我这样的演员，不幸的是还有乔尔，
on NBC, because I mean, The Office, you know, Thursday nights on NBC was the flagship show, and so when we found out that it would air after The Office, we were always, you know, that was like the anchor for us. And it's funny how you think certain shows like The Office has helped other shows. And then, you know, get on the air, stay on the air, and then give actors like myself, and unfortunately Joel,
一个职业生涯。那是，你知道，我很感激我的，你知道，但粉丝们应该后悔乔尔。我看着乔尔。你可以引用我的话。我们会。我们会。我们会把它用作这一集的宣传片段。
you know, a career. And that's been, you know, I'm grateful for mine, you know, but the fans should be regretting Joel. I'm looking at Joel. And you can quote me on that. We will. We will. We're gonna use that as our promo clip for this episode.
好了，在我们被粗鲁地打断之前。我知道，在乔尔·麦克哈尔进来并把我们的桌子搞得一团糟之前。他真的搞得一团糟。他打翻了一杯大头针。他移动了我们的咖啡和茶。我知道。我正要讨论我的速记事实。
All right, so before we were so rudely interrupted. I know, before Joel McHale came in and he trashed our desk. He literally trashed. He dumped over a cup of pins. He moved our coffee and our tea. I know. I was going to discuss my fast facts.
是的。速记事实第一条。这是编剧简·萨拉塔的第一集。我爱简·萨拉塔。现在她将继续编写粉丝最喜欢的剧集，如《海滩游戏》（Beach Games）和《本尼·哈纳圣诞节》（Benny Hana Christmas）等等。她还导演了几集，但这不仅是她作为编剧的第一集，而且我们爱简。
Yes. Fast fact number one. This is the first episode from writer Jen Salata. I love Jen Salata. Now she will go on to write fan favorites such as Beach Games and Benny Hauna Christmas and many more. She also directed several episodes, but this was her first episode as a writer, and we love Jen.
我关于简最喜欢的记忆之一，我想比任何其他编剧都多，就是她会在监视器后面咯咯笑。她的肩膀会颤抖。并不是说让她笑很容易，而是她准备好笑了。她准备好喜欢你正在做的事情了。明迪（Mindy）也是这样，我必须说。我只是喜欢她在片场的活力。
One of my favorite memories of Jen, I think more than any other writer, is she would giggle behind the monitor. And her shoulders would shake. It's not that it was easy to make her laugh, it was that she was ready to laugh. She was ready to love what you were doing. Mindy was like that too, I have to say. I just loved her energy on set.
我觉得这对演员有帮助，对吧？就像给表演者才华和信心，你知道？是的。而且简是那种人，因为她非常真诚和诚恳，所以当她笑的时候，就像她的整个身体都沉浸其中。这真是一个甜蜜、美妙的景象。确实是，确实是。好了，速记事实第二条。
I think that helps with the actors, right? Like just give the performers the talent for confidence, you know? Yeah. And Jen is the type of person, because she's so earnest and sincere, that when she does laugh, it's like her whole body gives into it. It's just a sweet, wonderful thing to witness. It really is, it really is. All right, fast fact number two.
来吧。看，它们很快，而且很快。哦天哪，我像慢动作的乔尔·麦克哈尔。没错。好了，我们这一集有两位大牌客串明星。第一位是奥米瓦迪亚（Omivadia），他饰演 IT 专家萨迪克（Sadiq）。现在，他也是那部叫《三傻大闹宝莱坞》（Three Idiots）的宝莱坞电影的主演。那是一部巨大的热门影片。
Do it. See, they're fast, and they're fast. Oh my God, I'm like slow-ly Joe McHale. That's right. All right, we have two big guest stars for this episode. The first is Omivadia, who plays the IT specialist, Sadiq. Now, he is also the star of this Bollywood movie called Three Idiots. It was a huge smash hit.
就像他是那部电影里的超级巨星。然后他也出现在我们这一集里，还有我们的另一位客串明星郑肯，他现在就在房间里。嗯，嗯，肯，当你得到《办公室》的角色时，我不认识你。我们几年后才见面。对。你能告诉我们一点你是怎么得到这个角色的吗？我以前是个医生，我以前是个内科医生，但我真的，我只是在下班后或午餐期间试镜。然后艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）看中了我就给了我一个《办公室》的试镜机会。而且，请记住，我真的没有任何银幕作品，但她直接把我带到了制片人面前。
Like he's just a gigantic star from this movie. And then he was also in our episode and our other guest star Ken Jeong who is in the room with us now. Well, well, Ken, I did not know you when you got the part in The Office. We met years later. Right. Can you tell us a little bit about how you got the part? I used to be a doctor, I used to be a physician, but I really I was auditioning just like during, like after work or during lunch. And then Allison Jones just took a liking to me and she got me an audition for The Office. And it was, keep in mind I really had no screen credits, but she brought me straight into producers.
我至今记忆犹新。那是在05年，我在简·萨拉塔和这一集的导演保罗·费格面前读了剧本。我是保罗在《怪胎与书呆子》（Freaks and Geeks）里的超级粉丝，所以我已经在办公室里像个书呆子一样了。我这么说不是因为你们是我的朋友，也不是因为这是《办公室女士》。这是我电视上最喜欢的节目。所以，我非常了解这个节目。所以，这真的是我第一次，也许是有史以来第一次，我被带去参加制片人读本，你知道，导演也在房间里。而且现在很有趣，因为很多人，理所当然地，
I still remember it vividly. It was in 05 and I had read in front of Jen Salata and Paul Feig, the director of the episode. And I was a huge fan of Paul's from Freaks and Geeks, so I was already just geeking out in the office. And I'm not saying it because you're my friends and because this is the office ladies. It was my favorite show on TV. So and I just a huge BBC office fan. So, I just knew the show inside out. And so, it was really one of the first times, maybe the first time ever, I was brought in for a producers read, you know, with the director in the room. And it's funny now because a lot of people, and rightly so,
认为我的表演非常夸张，非常，就像在《社区大学》里，你知道，非常非常只是把它推出来。而且非常，你知道，非常讽刺。就像真的，我认为我的突破性角色是演一些非常低调的东西，可能只有两句台词。我基本上会低语每一句台词，而且我即兴表演了一个看向镜头的表情，即使剧本里没有写。不错！我还记得，我至今记得我当时……
attribute my acting is very over-the-top and very, like on community, you know, very, very just pushing it out. And it's very, you know, very ironic. Like really, I think my breakthrough role was playing something very understated and with just maybe two lines. And I would basically whisper every line and I improvised a look to camera, even if it wasn't scripted. Nice! And I remember, I still remember where I go like,
他告诉我他不能说，但他有一把枪。我只是直视镜头，保罗·费格和简笑得太厉害了，因为这个小动作。那个小选择。那个小选择。我至今记得，保罗笑得停不下来。每当我见到保罗，我们还会谈论它。
he told me he couldn't say, but he has a gun. And I just looked straight down the barrel and Paul, Fig and Jen laughed so hard at this tiny movement. That little choice. That little choice. And I still remember like, Paul could not stop laughing. And whenever I see Paul, we still talk about it.
而且它仍然是，它是演员生活中那些事情之一，有时就像我忘记了在《社区大学》工作的几年，可能是因为乔尔。但是，我记得我在《办公室》里那大概三个小时的每一分钟。你知道，这真的，它是那些事情之一，我相信你们在你们的职业生涯中也有过，你只是记得你的第一次，你只是知道如果它不是一个分水岭事件，它也许是你最喜欢的事件。
And it's still, it's one of those things in an actor's life where sometimes like I've forgotten years of working on community, probably because of Joel. And, but I remember every single minute of my maybe three hours on the office. You know, it's just really, it's one of those things, and I'm sure you have that too in your careers of you just remember your first time and you just know if it's not a watershed event it's maybe your favorite event.
这就是《办公室》对我意味着什么。是的。哦，我喜欢那个。哇。这真是太美妙的分享了。我喜欢那个，肯。谢谢。非常感激。嗯，如果你不介意的话，我有一些粉丝问题
And that's kind of what the office means to me. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Wow. That's such a wonderful thing to share. I love that, Ken. Thank you. Very grateful. Well, I have some fan questions, if you don't mind
关于你在场景里的时间。杰森·P（Jason P）问，一旦你开始拍摄这些场景，有多少即兴表演是真的即兴表演？这是一个很好的问题。据我记忆，我记得我们按剧本拍了几次，只是为了确保我们有素材。然后看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell），实际上，我相信迪·瑞安（Dee Ryan），她也出现在那一集里，
answering about your time in the scene. Jason P asked, once you started shooting the scenes, how much of the improv was actually improv? That's a great question. To my memory, I remember we shot it a few times as scripted, just so we have it. And then to see Steve Carell and actually, I believe Dee Ryan, who was also in that episode,
是第二城市的同事。我从即兴奥林匹克（Improv Olympic）认识迪·瑞安，并和她一起在阿曼多·迪亚兹（Armando Diaz）的节目中表演过。哇。我认识迪，怀亚特·斯纳克（Wyatt Snack）也在那个场景里。怀亚特·斯纳克，最大的明星，乔·努涅斯（Joe Nunez），我认识他。还有迈克尔·诺顿（Michael Norton），他领导了即兴表演场景，饰演克里斯（Chris）。我几年前和他一起做过一个素描喜剧节目。
was a Second City colleague. I knew Dee Ryan from Improv Olympic and had performed with her in the Armando Diaz show. Wow. I knew Dee and Wyatt Snack was in that scene. Wyatt Snack, biggest star, Joe Nunez who I've known. And then also Michael Norton who led the improv scene who played Chris. I had done a sketch comedy show with him like years ago.
是的，好吧，等等，所以有即兴表演吗？在几次之后，我确实记得在几次剧本里的东西之后，他是 FBI 探员迈克尔·斯卡恩。当他结束时，当我们坐下来进行场景的尸检时，史蒂夫说，对不起，但她在整个场景里都在否定我。她在整个场景里都在否定我。那不在剧本里。他们一直争论不休。她说，你知道吗？至少我没有把这一切都“吉姆·凯瑞化”。他说，谢谢。他们就这样来回交流了整整两分钟。
Yes, okay wait, so was there improv? After a couple of, I do remember after a couple of things where it was in the script, he was FBI agent Michael Skarnlake. As soon as he ended, when we sit down for the postmortem of the scene, Steve goes, I'm sorry, but she was denying me in this whole scene. She was negating me this entire scene. That was not in the script. And they kept arguing back. And she goes, you know what? At least I'm not Jim Carrey-ing all this. And he goes, thank you. And they just had this whole back and forth exchange for literally two minutes.
然后她冲出了房间，冲出了教室。就像剧本写好的一样，当她转过身时，迈克尔·斯卡恩把枪抵在了她的后脑勺上。砰！我当时想，这是我第一次大的客串明星时刻或联合主演时刻，我想，我这辈子在片场从来没见过这种天才水平。
And then she storms out of the room, out of the class. And as if it was scripted, as soon as she had her back turn, Michael Scarn had the gun to the back of her head. Boom! And I was like, this is like my first big guest star moment or co-star moment, I'm like, I've just never seen this level of genius in my life on a set.
这是即兴表演之上的即兴表演，那一刻我永远不会忘记。所以我还有另一个粉丝问题。这是一个奇怪的问题，但我必须说我也注意到了。汉娜·本森（Hannah Benson）说，我确实注意到了。即兴表演场景里的每个人都有腋下汗渍。他们是不被允许开空调吗？那里真的很热吗？真的很热吗？我的意思是史蒂夫。当你们举手时，每个人都有腋下汗渍。史蒂夫举手时有一个巨大的汗渍。女人们！
It was this improv on top of an improv and that right there I'll just never forget. So I have another fan question. This is a weird one, but I have to say I noticed as well. Hannah Benson said, I did notice. Literally everyone in the improv scene has pit stains. Were they not allowed to have air conditioning? Was it real hot in there? Was it really hot? I mean Steve. When you guys raise your hands, everyone has a pit stain. Steve has a huge one when he raises his hands. The women!
我知道。即使是通常出汗较少的女性。肯笑得太厉害了。我不记得那些了。好吧，伙计们，你们可以回去看看那一集，当即兴表演课上的每个人举手时，那简直是汗水之城。那是一个出汗的日子。汉娜·本森和安吉拉和我都有注意到，但你不记得房间里特别热。不，我们在秋天拍的，我只记得当时很冷。我只记得当时很冷。我不得不穿，实际上，我在节目里穿的服装，那是我自己的衣服。
I know. Even the women who usually sweat less. Ken is like laughing so hard. I don't remember any of that. Well guys you can go back and look at the episode when everyone in the improv class raises their hand it is sweat city. It is a sweaty day. Hannah Benson and Angela and I all notice but you don't have a memory of it being terribly warm in the room. No we shot that in we shot that in the fall and I just remember it was cold it And I just remember it was cold. I just remember it was cold. I had to wear, actually, the wardrobe that I had on the show, that was my own clothes.
我相信那个。是的。是的。我在试播集里穿了我自己的衣服。真的？哇。我们当时预算很紧。是的，我有我自己的。
I believe that. Yeah. Yeah. I wore my own clothes in the pilot. Really? Wow. We were shoestring budget at this time. Yeah, I had my own.
我穿了一件滑雪夹克。那是我自己穿到片场的夹克。我的意思是，每个人，我当时是个新手，什么都不知道。我甚至自己涂了发胶，就像我只是……你自己做了头发。你准备好了。你穿戴整齐，准备好拍摄了。我准备好了，像《杜丝先生》（Tootsie），你知道吗？
I had a ski jacket on. That was my own jacket that I wore to set. I mean, everyone, I was such a greenhorn, just not knowing anything. I had even gelled my own, like I just. You did your own hair. You came ready. You showed up dressed and ready to shoot. I came ready like Tootsie, you know?
就像，我一切都准备好了。就像，我太菜了，我太菜了，我不知道。和史蒂夫演那个场景是什么感觉？直到今天，那仍然是我永远不会忘记的事情，因为他刚拍完《四十岁的老处男》（40-Year-Old Virgin），我上个月刚在电影院看过他，所以我正在和一个场景
It was like, I had everything ready. Like, it was, I was so green. I was so green, I had no idea. What was it like doing that scene with Steve? To this day, it's just something I'll never forget because he was coming off the 40-year-old Virgin, and I'd literally just watched him in the movie theater the previous month, and so I'm sharing a scene
分享喜剧界最大的明星。他真的是我的榜样，因为他真的是一个专业、优雅、有格调的演员，无论是在银幕上还是银幕下，他的表演都没有弱点。所以他只是我非常敬仰的人。说得太美了。不，真的太美了。哦天哪。他也是我的榜样，因为就像你谈到的，你在生活中，你现在对其他与你搭档的年轻演员来说就是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。
with the biggest star in comedy. He really is a role model to me because he really is just a professional, elegant, classy actor who has no weakness in his game, either on or off screen. So he's just someone that I just really look up to. That was so beautifully said. No, it really was. Oh my gosh. He's a role model to me too because kind of what you're talking about, you now in life, you are Steve Carell to other young actors who get paired with you.
我总是记得我回顾史蒂夫对待人们的方式，我想这就是我想成为的样子。如果我有一天处于我就是那一刻的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的位置，就像不是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，但在那一刻，我想像他那样表现。我想变得慷慨、体贴、给予，并且温暖、欢迎这个对系统来说全新的演员。是的，我记得和他谈过。我在 ABC 有过一个短命的情景喜剧，拍了几年，是我创作和编写的。
And I always remember I look back on how Steve treated people and I think that's how I want to be. If I'm ever in a position where I'm the Steve Carell of a moment, like not Steve Carell but within a moment, I want to behave like he did. I want to be generous and thoughtful and giving and warm and inviting of this actor who's brand new to the system. Yeah, I remember talking to him. I had a short-lived sitcom on ABC for a couple years that I created and wrote.
我在某个地方遇到了史蒂夫，我向他寻求建议，他实际上，他说，你知道，以身作则永远不会错。只要嘿，如果你不表现得难相处，那么没人会表现得难相处。我记得他告诉过我。而且，是的，我记得当，就像他说的那样，我有一个时刻，我记得对自己说，如果我努力工作，其他人也会努力工作。
And I had run into Steve somewhere and I had asked him for advice and he actually, he had said, you know, you can't go wrong with just leading by example. Just hey, if you're not going to act difficult, then nobody's going to act difficult. I remember he told me that. And it was, yeah, and I remember thinking about that when, like he said, I had a moment and I remember thinking to myself, if I work hard, everyone else will work hard.
肯，非常感谢。你在开玩笑吗？谢谢你们邀请我。过来。我真的谢谢你们。真的。为你们干杯。恭喜你们。我只是……你们花时间陪我们真是太慷慨了。
Ken, thank you so much. Are you kidding? Thank you for having me. For coming in. I really thank you. Truly. Cheers to you guys. Congrats on this. And I just- So generous of you to give us your time.
不，这是我最喜欢的客串演出。《办公室》是我最喜欢的客串演出。它真的帮助启动了我的职业生涯。所以谢谢。好吧，听着，我们没演过《社区大学》，我们俩都没演过。但当你和乔尔做《社区敌人》时，我们会来的。是的，你们会是执行制片人。我们只是进来然后……
No, the office was my favorite guest star appearance ever. Congrats on this. And I just- So generous of you to give us your time. The Office was my favorite guest star appearance ever. It really just helped jumpstart my career. So thank you. Well, listen, we were not on Community, neither of us. But when you and Joel do Community Enemies, we will come on. Yes, you guys will be EPs. We'll just come in and-
你们会给我们提意见。我们会冲进你们的房间。是的，你们会冲进房间，给我们提意见。嘿，也许一点友谊会出现在这一集里。我只是要进来对乔尔竖中指，把他的大头针倒在他的膝盖上。成交。
You'll be giving us notes. We'll storm your room. Yeah, you'll storm the room, give us notes. Hey, maybe a little bit of friendship could show up in this episode. I'm just gonna come in and flip off Joel and dump his pins on his lap. Done.
我们是反办公室，我和乔尔。这全是格调、乐趣、尊严，然后是我和乔尔。你们的开场白可以是，你知道，我们每周会看一集《社区大学》，我们会给你们提供所有只有两个互相憎恨的人才能告诉你们的幕后信息和琐事。是的。而且真的……我们会告诉你们所有的争吵。是的。所有的。
We're the anti-office, me and Joel. This is all class, fun, dignity, and then me and Joel. Your intro can be, you know, we're gonna give each week, we're gonna watch an episode of Community and we're gonna give you all the behind-the-scenes info and trivia that only two people who hate one another can tell you. Yes. And really- We're gonna tell you all the fights. Yeah. All of the.
并进行深入探讨。所有的紧张。进行深入探讨，批评彼此的表演。表演和生活中的一切，显然。而且像个人的。个人的。个人的选择，不仅仅是专业的。像身体攻击。
And do a deep dive. All of the tension. Do a deep dive critiquing each other's performance. And performance and lot in life apparently. And like personal. Personal. Personal choices, not just professional. Like physical attacks.
是的，身体攻击。我知道。好了，肯，非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢你们。我们要休息一下，然后回来解析这一集的其余部分。这是一年中最甜蜜的时光。没错，情人节快到了，梅西百货有最好的礼物
Yeah, physical attacks. I know. All right, Kim, thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you guys. We're gonna take a break and then we'll be back to break down the rest of this episode. It's the sweetest time of year. That's right, Valentine's Day is approaching and Macy's has the best of the best gifts
给你的爱人。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为你的送礼指南。我喜欢在 Macy's.com 上购物。他们真的，真的什么都有。他们的礼物指南太棒了。我从梅西百货的礼物指南中得到了很多好主意。我今年大概在 Macy's.com 上完成了三分之二的圣诞购物。
for your loved ones. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. I love shopping on Macy's.com. They really, really do have everything. And their gift guide is amazing. I've gotten so many good ideas from the Macy's gift guide. I did probably 2 thirds of my Christmas shopping on Macy's.com this year.
和我的孩子们一起，我们情人节会送一份礼物，一份小礼物，而不是糖果。我们情人节不送礼物，一份小礼物，而不是糖果。我们不吃太多糖果。万圣节、圣诞袜等等已经有很多糖果了。所以当我们到情人节时，我喜欢为他们包装一点小东西。梅西百货为你生活中的成年爱人和孩子爱人提供了保障。选购梅西百货的礼物指南，为名单上的每个人挑选完美的精选商品。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为你的送礼指南。在店内或在线访问 macys.com/giftguide 购物。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道你经常听到
With my kids, we do a gift for Valentine's Day, a small gift instead of candy. We don't do a gift for Valentine's Day, a small gift, instead of candy. We don't do a lot of candy. There's been enough candy with Halloween and the Christmas stocking and all of that. So when we get to Valentine's Day, I like to wrap up a little something for them. Macy's has got you covered for the adult loved one in your life and the kid loved one in your life. Shop Macy's gift guides for the perfect hand-picked items for everyone on your list. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop in store or online at macy's.com slash gift guide. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know you often hear
关于恋爱关系中要注意的红旗，但如果，如果我们改变这种关注点，开始列出我们在朋友和伴侣身上寻找的绿旗清单呢？你知道，就像与其设定我正在避免什么，不如说这是我想奔向的目标。好的。好吧，如果你不确定你的绿旗清单是什么，治疗可以帮助你识别它们。而且你知道 BetterHelp 是完全在线的，让治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。
about like the red flags to look for in a relationship, but what if, what if we like changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners? You know like more like instead of framing it here's what I'm avoiding be like here's what I want to run toward. Okay. Well if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know BetterHelp is fully online, making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide.
你可以访问一个拥有超过30,000名持证治疗师的多样化网络，他们拥有广泛的专业领域。你也可以随时免费更换治疗师。用 BetterHelp 发现你的关系绿旗。今天访问 BetterHelp.com/officeladies，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是 Better Help，H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。本集由三星 Galaxy 赞助。曾经捕捉到精彩的夜间视频吗？请。现在 brief 将根据你的日常安排为你提供个性化的见解，以便你无论发生什么都能做好准备。现在就在 Samsung.com 购买三星 Galaxy S25 Ultra。好了，我们回来了。我们回来了。谢谢，郑肯。不谢谢，乔尔·麦克哈尔。不谢谢，乔尔·麦克哈尔。如果你在追踪，也许你在追踪，我希望你在追踪，我们
You can access a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. This episode is brought to you by Samsung Galaxy. Ever captured a great night video Please. now brief will give you personalized insights based on your day schedule so that you're prepared no matter what. Buy the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra now at Samsung.com. Okay, we're back. We are back. Thank you, Ken Jeong. And not thank you, Joel McHale. Not thank you, Joel McHale. If you're tracking, and maybe you are, I hope you are, that we
没有做我们的第三个速记事实。我们没有。这是一个特别的速记事实。它很特别，因为安吉拉和我都在找我们的日记。我们找到了我们在每一集之后，有时在每一集期间写的日记。是的。伙计们，我写日记写了很久了。
did not do our third fast fact. We did not. And it's a special fast fact. It's special because Angela and I both found our journals. We found our journals that we wrote in after each episode, sometimes during an episode. Yeah. You guys, I have journaled for so long.
我，我在布置我的“她的小屋”（she shed）时找到了12本日记。哦天哪。我有太多话要说了。我从会写字开始就一直在写日记。我的意思是，我有关于我在二年级暗恋对象的日记。我找到了一本大学时的日记，我当时想，这是谁？我告诉你，她有一段时间真的迷恋上了一个家伙。在这篇日记里，我写了关于《办公室》这一集的具体内容。这是我写的。这是一个宝石。我们拍摄这一集时连续下了三天雨。拍一集需要五天，五天里有三天都在下雨，就像
I have, I found like in setting up my she shed, 12 journals. Oh my gosh. I had so much to say. I've been journaling since I could write. I mean, I have journals about my crushes in second grade. I found a journal from college that is like, I'm like, who is this person? I'll tell you what, she was real hung up on a certain fella for a while. In this journal entry, I wrote about this exact episode of The Office. Here's what I wrote. Here's a gem. It rained for three days while we were shooting this episode. It takes five days to shoot an episode and for three of the five days, it rained like
我在布置我的小屋时，发现了12本日志。天哪。我有太多话想说了。我从会写字起就开始写日记了。我是说，我甚至有关于小学二年级暗恋对象的日记。我发现了一本大学时的日记，当时我就想，这人是谁啊？我跟你说，她当时确实对某个家伙念念不忘了一阵子。在这篇日记里，我写到了《办公室》的这一集。这是我写的内容。这可是个宝贝。我们拍这一集的时候连下了三天雨。拍一集需要五天，而五天里有三天都在下雨，就像
downpour heavy rains, apparently. Torrential rain. I noted that our AD Richard had to wear a parka. He's the person who would knock on our trailer doors and get us to come from our trailers across the parking lot onto the stages. It was a little bit of a walk you guys and this parking lot would flood. There'd be huge puddles of water. Yes. And I guess it really caused a problem for hair, makeup, and wardrobe because we would get ready outside in our trailers.
显然是倾盆大雨。暴雨。我注意到我们的助理导演理查德不得不穿上派克大衣。他就是那个会敲我们的拖车门，让我们从拖车里出来，穿过停车场走到舞台上的人。伙计们，那段路有点远，而且这个停车场会积水。会有巨大的水坑。是的。我想这对发型、化妆和服装部门来说确实造成了麻烦，因为我们是在外面的拖车里做准备的。
And then by the time we got to set, we were drenched. And I wrote all about it in my journal. I said that we had umbrellas. We each got an umbrella with our name on it. Remember that? Yeah. They would give a little sticker so that it could keep track. I have to share with you that I often would misplace my umbrella and I would just take
等我们到达片场时，我们已经湿透了。我在日记里写了所有关于这件事的内容。我说我们有雨伞。我们每个人都拿到了一把写有自己名字的雨伞。记得吗？是的。他们会给一个小贴纸，这样就能追踪到。我必须告诉你们，我经常会弄丢我的雨伞，然后我就直接拿
someone else's. Angela! And then I would hear Richard on the radio being like, has anyone seen John's umbrella? Anyone? I'd be like, eh, it might be in my trailer. I also noted, speaking of John, that John's birthday was the week that we shot this episode. He turned 26. 26? Yeah. Oh my Lord, that's so birthday was the week that we shot this episode. He turned 26. 26. Yeah. Oh my Lord, that's so young.
别人的。安吉拉！然后我会在对讲机里听到理查德说，有人看到约翰的雨伞了吗？有人吗？我会说，呃，可能在我的拖车里。我还注意到，说到约翰，约翰的生日就在我们拍摄这一集的那一周。他26岁了。26岁？是的。天哪，那太年轻了。
I know. He and BJ and Mindy were all the youngsters. I don't know. They were youngins. Because the rest of us were all in our 30s and beyond, but they were still in their 20s. Wowzers. Okay, so I also wrote my journal. Now, I wrote about some things that happen at Gem's party and a few other places in the episode. I'm going to save those, Jenna. Okay. But I will tell you one thing I wrote about some things that happen at Jim's party and a few other places in the episode. I'm going to save those, Jenna. Okay. But I will tell you one thing I wrote about. Jenna, we carpooled to work this week.
我知道。他和BJ还有敏迪都是年轻人。我不知道。他们是小年轻。因为我们其他人都在30岁以上，但他们还在20多岁。哇哦。好吧，我也写了我的日记。现在，我写了一些在吉姆的派对和其他几个地方发生的事情。我要把那些留着，珍娜。好的。但我会告诉你一件事，我写了一些在吉姆的派对和其他几个地方发生的事情。我要把那些留着，珍娜。好的。但我会告诉你一件事。珍娜，我们这周是拼车上班的。
When we were shooting this episode? Yes. I wrote that we had to go on location. We were very excited because Jim's party, his barbecue happened at his apartment and we got to drive to location. And I wrote that you and I carpooled and we had the best time. I wrote, I was like, we chatted, we sang songs, and you know, we solved the world's problems. That's what I wrote.
我们拍这一集的时候吗？是的。我写道我们必须去外景地。我们非常兴奋，因为吉姆的派对，他的烧烤是在他公寓举行的，我们得开车去外景地。我写道你和我拼车，我们玩得很开心。我写道，我当时想，我们聊天，我们唱歌，你知道，我们解决了世界难题。这就是我写的。
I do not remember that. I don't remember it either, but we clearly had a great time. I love that you wrote that down because I'm sure we did do that. Cause we lived really close. We lived really close and we were probably so excited that we had a commute. We had to drive far and I said it was a little bit of a drive but the thing that really cracked me up is I said we sang our hearts out and we solved the world's problems. We probably did. What did we
我不记得了。我也不记得了，但我们显然玩得很开心。我很高兴你把它写下来了，因为我相信我们确实那样做了。因为我们住得很近。我们住得很近，而且我们可能太兴奋了，因为我们有通勤。我们得开很远的车，我说那段路有点远，但真正让我笑出声的是我说我们尽情歌唱，解决了世界难题。我们可能真的做了。我们唱了什么
sing Jenna? What did we sing? I'd love to know. I wish I knew. Sounds of Scranton. Oh, I hope we sang Sounds of Scranton. All right, so let's get into this episode now. We're gonna start breaking it down. It starts with the cold open. Yes, so Sadiq is coming to fix an IT problem, right? And Michael looks out his window, he sees him coming. He panics, because probably Michael has some growing
珍娜？我们唱了什么？我很想知道。我希望我知道。斯克兰顿之声。哦，我希望我们唱的是斯克兰顿之声。好了，现在让我们进入这一集。我们要开始拆解它了。它从冷开场开始。是的，所以萨迪克来修理一个IT问题，对吧？迈克尔从窗户往外看，他看到了他走过来。他惊慌失措，因为迈克尔可能在如何看待他人方面还有一些
in maturity to do about how he perceives others. That's how I'm going to say it. That's a good way to put it. He has some maturing to do. So anyway, he freaks out. He wants to turn off the lights and have everyone hide. But do you remember how we couldn't get it coordinated, Jenna?
成熟度需要提升。我会这么说。这是一种很好的说法。他还有一些成熟的空间。总之，他吓坏了。他想关掉灯，让大家都躲起来。但你还记得我们是怎么没能协调好的吗，珍娜？
We couldn't turn off the lights at the right time. Yes. People should know that in this scene when Michael runs over to shut off the light switches, those light switches do not actually operate the lights. The lights are controlled by a grid and a guy who's in charge of them. And so what they would do is they would have someone on a radio who would see when Steve hit the light switch and then they would radio go and then the light switch guy would actually turn off the lights. But it didn't always work. So sometimes Steve would hit the
我们没能在正确的时间关掉灯。是的。人们应该知道，在这一幕中，当迈克尔跑过去关掉电灯开关时，那些电灯开关实际上并不控制灯光。灯光是由电网和负责它们的人控制的。所以他们会做的是，他们会安排一个人在对讲机上，看到史蒂夫按下电灯开关时，他们就会通过对讲机说“走”，然后电灯开关操作员才会真正关掉灯。但这并不总是奏效。所以有时史蒂夫会按下
switch and the lights would just stay on or sometimes they would anticipate too quickly and the lights would go off before he hit the switch. Again, this is one of those moments where I'm like, thank God we didn't have to do any car chases or explosions because it seems like the light switch was like really tricky for us. I have to ask you one thing. Okay, so Sadiq from IT is coming to help Michael, right? I just have to say this, Jenna, at one minute, 26 seconds,
开关，灯却一直亮着，或者有时他们预判得太快，灯在他按下开关之前就灭了。再说一次，这是那些让我觉得谢天谢地我们不需要做任何汽车追逐或爆炸的时刻之一，因为看起来电灯开关对我们来说真的很棘手。我必须问你一件事。好吧，所以IT部门的萨迪克来帮迈克尔，对吧？我不得不说，珍娜，在1分26秒时，
this actually like, I thought about this for days after watching this episode. This actually, like, I thought about this for days. What? After watching this episode. Michael says he tried to install the software himself, but it was password protected. Sadiq says, that just means you have to enter your password. Does this mean that Sadiq didn't even have to come there? If Michael had just entered one, two, three, 1234 that was on the post-it note,
这实际上，我在看完这一集后的几天里一直在想这件事。这实际上，我在看完这一集后的几天里一直在想这件事。什么？迈克尔说他试图自己安装软件，但它有密码保护。萨迪克说，那只是意味着你必须输入你的密码。这是否意味着萨迪克根本不需要来这里？如果迈克尔只是输入了贴在便签纸上的1234，
had he just entered that, the software would have installed? I think that's what that means. So that is so like, if you put that in perspective, Sadiq is probably like, this idiot. All he had to do was enter the password I put on a post-it note and tape to his desktop. It also feels like something that could have been solved with a phone call. Yes. He definitely did not need to come into the office and be subjected to Michael's cold open.
如果他只是输入了那个，软件就会安装了吗？我想这就是那个意思。所以这太像了，如果你从这个角度看，萨迪克可能在想，这个白痴。他所要做的就是输入我写在便签纸上并贴在他桌面上的密码。这也感觉像是可以通过一个电话解决的事情。是的。他绝对不需要来到办公室，还要忍受迈克尔的冷开场。
No. No. Oh my gosh. So at one minute 46 seconds, Dwight surprises Michael outside of his office, right? He's demanding to know why the IT guy is there. And of course, Michael doesn't want to tell him because it's going to be revealed that he's there to install software so that Michael can spy on everybody's emails. Well, I want you to look in the background of this scene. As Steve's coming out the door,
不。不。天哪。所以在1分46秒时，德怀特在办公室外让迈克尔大吃一惊，对吧？他要求知道IT人员为什么在那里。当然，迈克尔不想告诉他，因为这会暴露他是为了安装软件，以便迈克尔可以监视每个人的电子邮件。好吧，我希望你看看这一幕的背景。当史蒂夫走出门口时，
he quickly shuts the door behind him. That's because Omi was not there on that day of filming. So he had to quickly shut the door. Steve has to shimmy out and then shut the door behind him so that you won't see that the office is actually empty. Oh, look at you with your little behind the scenes nugget. Yes. All right, at two minutes, 14 seconds, Dwight lists off what could possibly happen to Michael
他迅速关上了身后的门。那是因为奥米那天没去拍摄。所以他必须迅速关上门。史蒂夫必须扭动着出来，然后关上身后的门，这样你就不会看到办公室实际上是空的。哦，看看你，带着你的小幕后花絮。是的。好吧，在2分14秒时，德怀特列出了可能发生在迈克尔身上
so that he might take over the office. Right? Yeah. Here are the things that could happen. Okay. Number one, brain aneurysm. Number two, getting hit by a car, a bus or a train. Number three, poisoned, fall down a well, step on a mine. These are like Dwight has thought this out, you guys. This is what could happen and he'd have to do an immediate takeover. Immediate takeover. And Michael has that great line where he says, you know what, Dwight, if I step on a mine in Scranton, Pennsylvania, you can have my job.
的事情，这样他就可以接管办公室了。对吧？是的。这些是可能发生的事情。第一，脑动脉瘤。第二，被车、公共汽车或火车撞到。第三，中毒，掉进井里，踩到地雷。这些就像是德怀特已经想好了，伙计们。这就是可能发生的事情，他将不得不立即接管。立即接管。迈克尔有一句很棒的台词，他说，你知道吗，德怀特，如果我在宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿踩到地雷，你可以接手我的工作。
He's so annoyed. Yeah. So the next big scene is kind of in the bullpen when Oscar confronts Michael about spying on everyone's emails. He does it in front of everyone. I loved it whenever Oscar confronted Michael in front of everyone. And he does this throughout the series.
他太烦了。是的。所以下一个大场景是在办公区，奥斯卡就监视大家电子邮件的事质问迈克尔。他在所有人面前这样做。我喜欢奥斯卡在所有人面前质问迈克尔的时候。他在整个系列中都这样做。
And it's just some of my favorite moments of the show. He is able to take Michael to task like no one else. I think Stanley also does this from time to time, but Stanley is usually more under his breath, right? Like he's a little more to the side about it. In this scene, Steve does this never ending robot bit. Oscar's trying to get a word out and Steve just keeps doing the robot thing. I remember shooting that. So in the script, that was not supposed to go on for that long. That was supposed to just be like a quick little thing, but Steve
这只是我最喜欢的剧集时刻之一。他能够像其他人一样让迈克尔承担责任。我想斯坦利也会不时这样做，但斯坦利通常更小声，对吧？就像他对此更侧面一点。在这一幕中，史蒂夫一直在做那个没完没了的机器人动作。奥斯卡试图说一句话，而史蒂夫一直在做机器人动作。我记得拍摄那一幕。所以在剧本里，那不应该持续那么久。那应该只是一个小动作，但史蒂夫
really dragged it out. And that was an example, I think, of some of his just brilliant comedic timing. I honestly think that Steve would drag things out like that to see when he could get all of us to break. And we would break. He did break in that. He was a little sadistic that way. He'd be like, Oh, you haven't broken yet. How about this? Yeah. How about this? Kenzie, I see you going. Like, just keep going until we fell apart. Well, right after this, then, we have the little aside. Well, the erasing begins, right? The erasing begins.
真的把它拖得很长。我认为这是他一些天才喜剧时机的一个例子。我真心认为史蒂夫会那样拖延事情，看看什么时候能让我们所有人都笑场。我们确实笑场了。他确实在那一幕里笑场了。他在这方面有点虐待狂。他会说，哦，你还没笑场吗？这个怎么样？是的。这个怎么样？肯齐，我看到你要笑了。就像，一直继续直到我们崩溃。好吧，就在这之后，我们有了那个小旁白。好吧，删除开始了，对吧？删除开始了。
And Dwight says to Angela, if you have any sensitive emails, they need to be deleted immediately. Mm-hmm. Pam overhears. She calls Jim over. She suspects that they might be a couple. This is the first moment where we call out that Dwight and Angela might be together. Well, the first moment that anyone in the office has any idea, right?
德怀特对安吉拉说，如果你有任何敏感的电子邮件，需要立即删除。嗯哼。帕姆听到了。她叫来吉姆。她怀疑他们可能是一对。这是我们第一次指出德怀特和安吉拉可能在一起的时刻。好吧，这是办公室里任何人有任何想法的第一个时刻，对吧？
Yes. Yeah. Fan question from Kelsey McGrath, Angela, when did Angela and Rain find out that they were love interests? I mean, I'm not sure if Rain had any heads up before I did, but I found out at the table read. Really? Yeah, when we sat down to read the script and Oscar- So no one warned you beforehand?
是的。是的。来自凯尔西·麦格拉思的粉丝提问，安吉拉，安吉拉和雷恩是什么时候发现他们是恋爱对象的？我是说，我不确定雷恩是否比我先得到消息，但我是在剧本朗读会上发现的。真的吗？是的，当我们坐下来读剧本时，奥斯卡——所以没有人提前警告你？
No one warned me beforehand. I had no idea. And when we sat down at the table read and we read that their Birkenstocks were bumping, right? I was like, ah! Well, I remember there was an audible gasp in the room when we read that there were times when we would do these table reads where people would be legitimately surprised by plot twists and this was definitely one of them. This when we found out Oscar was gay. Yes. Right? Yes.
没有人提前警告我。我完全不知道。当我们坐在剧本朗读会上，读到他们的勃肯鞋在碰撞时，对吧？我当时想，啊！好吧，我记得当我们读到那一段时，房间里发出了一声明显的惊呼。我们读剧本时，有时人们会因为情节转折而感到真正惊讶，这绝对是其中之一。这是我们发现奥斯卡是同性恋的时候。是的。对吧？是的。
I mean, when we found out Jim and Pam were going to have a baby. Yes. I mean, there were these big moments, but I did not know. And I remember being like, oh my God. And I definitely don't think a lot of the cast members knew. Because there were real reactions there. Yes. I also, I know we're going back a little bit,
我是说，当我们发现吉姆和帕姆要生孩子的时候。是的。我是说，有这些大时刻，但我不知道。我记得当时想，天哪。我绝对不认为很多演员知道。因为那里有真实的反应。是的。我也，我知道我们要回溯一点，
but I love that Kevin says he has to delete a lot. A lot. Gross, Kevin. What's going on over there? Pam has a talking head next. Oh, wait. Can I say one thing? Yeah. Jenna, just to go back to Jim and Pam's conversation about Dwight and Angela. Yeah. This happens at four minutes, 45 seconds. I want you guys to rewatch the scene. Pam is so grossed out. So is Jim. At the idea of Dwight and Angela, they were like, ugh, I'm just like, come on.
但我喜欢凯文说他必须删除很多。很多。恶心，凯文。那边发生了什么？帕姆接下来有一个独白。哦，等等。我能说一件事吗？是的。珍娜，回到吉姆和帕姆关于德怀特和安吉拉的对话。是的。这发生在4分45秒。我希望你们重看这一幕。帕姆感到非常恶心。吉姆也是。对于德怀特和安吉拉的想法，他们当时说，呃，我只是想，得了吧。
That's, what's wrong with that? Two people falling in love. Pam was like, ugh, I can't, ugh. We are a little over the top about it. You're so grossed out by it. I was like, geez. Well, Pam then goes and has a talking head where she says directly to the documentary film crew, if you see anything, let me know.
那，那有什么错？两个人坠入爱河。帕姆当时说，呃，我不能，呃。我们对此有点夸张。你对此感到非常恶心。我当时想，天哪。好吧，帕姆然后去了一个独白，她说直接对纪录片摄制组说，如果你看到什么，让我知道。
Oh, yeah. She's like all chummy with the documentary crew. She full on invites them to help. I think this is the first time we see this moment where someone in the show speaks directly to the character of the documentarian, who we never see. But yeah. Yeah, I think that Pam and Jim probably
哦，是的。她就像和纪录片摄制组很亲近。她完全邀请他们帮忙。我认为这是我们第一次看到这一幕，剧中有人直接与我们从未见过的纪录片制作者的角色对话。但是的。是的，我想帕姆和吉姆可能
are the two people that engage with them the most. I mean, Michael, because he's a showboat. But it's like Pam knows them. That's what it felt like in that moment. Yeah, like they're kind of friends or something. Yeah. All right, so something else in Pam's talking head. At four minutes, 57 seconds, I'm tracking the mail cart now.
是与他们互动最多的人。我是说，迈克尔，因为他是个爱出风头的人。但感觉就像帕姆认识他们。那一刻就是这种感觉。是的，就像他们是朋友什么的。是的。好吧，帕姆的独白里还有别的东西。在4分57秒，我现在在追踪邮件车。
She is, you guys. She's become obsessed with the mail cart. I'm tracking Casual Fridays and the mail cart. And I want you all to know that Meredith comes over to the mail cart behind me during my talking head. Thank you. I'm applauding Jonah's mail cart tracking. The mail cart got used.
她是，伙计们。她已经对邮件车着迷了。我在追踪休闲星期五和邮件车。我希望你们都知道，在我独白时，梅雷迪思走到我身后的邮件车旁。谢谢。我为珍娜的邮件车追踪鼓掌。邮件车被使用了。
And then at five minutes, 12 seconds, there's just this interaction between Pam and Dwight that I love. I actually love Pam and Dwight scenes. They're some of my favorite. You are often so just exasperated by him. And it's one of my favorite things you do is Pam. She comes up to him.
然后在5分12秒，帕姆和德怀特之间有这种互动，我非常喜欢。我实际上喜欢帕姆和德怀特的场景。它们是我最喜欢的场景之一。你经常对他感到非常恼火。这是我作为帕姆最喜欢做的事情之一。她走到他面前。
Pam's on the case. She's very excited. Detective Pam. She's like, Dwight. So my friend is kind of, you know, into these two girls. And Dwight's like, nice. And your face is like, oh, God. At five minutes, 41 seconds, we find out that Dwight as a volunteer sheriff goes through everyone's medical records. So that's great. Gross. Gross Dwight. My gosh. All right, Jenna, I have a thing that I track, it's called old tech.
帕姆在处理这件事。她非常兴奋。侦探帕姆。她说，德怀特。所以我的朋友有点，你知道，喜欢这两个女孩。德怀特说，不错。你的表情就像，哦，天哪。在5分41秒，我们发现德怀特作为志愿警长查看了每个人的医疗记录。所以这很棒。恶心。恶心，德怀特。天哪。好吧，珍娜，我有一个我追踪的东西，叫做旧技术。
Oh yeah, what's your old tech track? Guys, I think we should just call this the we tracked it episode. The we tracked it. We're on the case. We're on the case. Much like Pam, we're on the case. I love me some old tech and at five minutes 57 seconds,
哦，是的，你的旧技术追踪是什么？伙计们，我觉得我们应该直接把这一集称为“我们追踪了它”这一集。我们追踪了它。我们在处理这件事。我们在处理这件事。就像帕姆一样，我们在处理这件事。我喜欢旧技术，在5分57秒，
you see the Evite and you see it's like so outdated looking. If you go to eVite now it's like it looks like the old eVites of that day and age if you will. Yes this is the scene where Michael is discovering the eVite and he learns that Jim is having a barbecue at his house and he is not invited. He's not invited. He sees the list of people who are invited and he is sort of looking around. He's not invited. He sees the list of people who are invited. And he is sort of looking around. He's using his mouse, right? Yeah.
你看到了电子邀请函，你看到它看起来非常过时。如果你现在去电子邀请函网站，它看起来就像那个时代的旧电子邀请函，如果你愿意的话。是的，这是迈克尔发现电子邀请函的一幕，他得知吉姆在他家举行烧烤派对，而他没有被邀请。他没有被邀请。他看到了被邀请的人名单，他正在四处张望。他没有被邀请。他看到了被邀请的人名单。他正在四处张望。他在用鼠标，对吧？是的。
And it all is so old looking. Super old graphic. Yeah. So next, Detective Pam walks up to Angela at the vending machine. Oh, you guys. This is like some of my favorite stuff. I also wrote about this in my journal.
而且看起来都很旧。超级旧的图形。是的。所以接下来，侦探帕姆走到自动售货机旁的安吉拉身边。哦，伙计们。这就像我最喜欢的东西。我也在我的日记里写了这件事。
I wrote, you guys, Jenna and I have a scene together. We're so excited. We did get so excited when we had scenes together. We were horrible because then we would just laugh and be idiots once we were in the scene. And they would take forever and people would get like really tired of us. It's true. But we were really excited about this scene. We were. I asked Angela if she's bringing anyone to the party and Angela says no. But then Angela buys an extra candy bar. Yeah, two Baby Ruth bars. Evidence. Fan question. Michael and Kristen Mulligan want to know why did you choose Baby Ruth for you and Dwight? Did you, Angela, the person get to choose what the candy would be or was it scripted?
我写道，伙计们，珍娜和我有一个共同的场景。我们太兴奋了。当我们有共同的场景时，我们确实非常兴奋。我们很糟糕，因为一旦进入场景，我们就会大笑，像白痴一样。他们会花很长时间，人们会因为我们而感到非常疲倦。这是真的。但我们对这一幕非常兴奋。我们是。我问安吉拉她是否带人参加派对，安吉拉说没有。但后来安吉拉买了一根额外的糖果棒。是的，两根宝贝露丝棒。证据。粉丝提问。迈克尔和克里斯汀·穆里根想知道为什么你为自己和德怀特选择了宝贝露丝？是你，安吉拉本人，选择了糖果是什么，还是剧本写的？
Usually Phil Shea, our props guy, would give us a few options and there were options that had been cleared because for legal reasons you have to make sure you can use logos and things like that. So they probably gave us a few options. I actually love Baby Ruth bars. So I guess I want, I'm sure I was like, oh Baby Ruth bar and goodness, I guess Frayne agreed cause he had to eat one too. No kidding. Yeah. So I think that's probably how it went down. I want to point out though, you guys,
通常，我们的道具师菲尔·谢伊会给我们几个选择，而且有一些选择是已经通过审核的，因为出于法律原因，你必须确保可以使用标志之类的东西。所以他们可能给了我们几个选择。我实际上很喜欢宝贝露丝棒。所以我猜我当时想，哦，宝贝露丝棒，天哪，我猜弗雷恩同意了，因为他也得吃一个。不是开玩笑的。是的。所以我认为事情可能就是这样发生的。不过我想指出，伙计们，
one of the things I love in this scene is that as Pam goes to pick something from the vending machine, I swat her hand away and I'm like, excuse me. I love it whenever my character would just swat someone away. It's so dismissive. It just made me laugh. AMTHA PURDALL-MORGAL
在这一幕中我喜欢的一件事是，当帕姆去自动售货机拿东西时，我拍开了她的手，我说，打扰一下。每当我的角色拍开某人时，我都喜欢。这太轻蔑了。这让我笑了。
Pam was probably going to buy some of her chips. AMTHA PURDALL-MORGAL Her gross smelly chips. AMTHA PURDALL-MORGAL Okay. Also Angela, in this scene at six minutes, 47 seconds, there is a really great shot as you're bending down to get the snaps of your ponytail. I know it sounded like I was going to say something else. It's your ponytail. There's a great shot of your ponytail. AMTHA PURDALL-MORGAL It's a family show, lady. AMTHA PURDALL-MORGAL I know. AMT I was gonna say something else. It's your ponytail.
帕姆可能打算买她的一些薯片。她那些恶心又难闻的薯片。好吧。还有安吉拉，在这一幕中，在6分47秒，当你弯腰去拿零食时，有一个非常棒的镜头，拍到了你的马尾辫。我知道听起来我要说别的东西了。是你的马尾辫。有一个很棒的镜头拍到了你的马尾辫。这是家庭节目，女士。我知道。我本来要说别的东西。是你的马尾辫。
There's a great shot of your ponytail. It's a family show, lady. I know. Yes. You've got like hair. Wrapped around my own hair. Yeah, describe it. Okay, this is a classic Kim Ferry thing
有一个很棒的镜头拍到了你的马尾辫。这是家庭节目，女士。我知道。是的。你有那种头发。缠绕在我自己的头发上。是的，描述一下。好吧，这是一个经典的基姆·费里风格，
where even the ponytails were amazing. She would pull my hair back in this sort of severe ponytail, but then she would leave a big chunk of it out and she would wrap it around the ponytail holder. So it looks like my own hair is holding up the ponytail. It's very polished looking. I know. And it's very Angela Martin to do this detail.
连马尾辫都很棒。她会把我的头发扎成这种严谨的马尾辫，但她会留出一大块，然后把它缠绕在马尾辫发圈上。所以看起来就像我自己的头发在支撑着马尾辫。看起来非常精致。我知道。而且这非常安吉拉·马丁，会做这种细节。
Very Angela Martin to do it. But I used to joke with Kim, I would be like, how early does Angela get up to do these elaborate braids? And also, is she an octopus? Like, how does she get back there? How many, does she have like a mirror behind her head? Like, what does her bathroom look like?
非常安吉拉·马丁。但我过去常和基姆开玩笑，我会说，安吉拉多早起床做这些复杂的辫子？而且，她是章鱼吗？她是怎么弄到后面的？她有多少，她脑后有镜子吗？她的浴室看起来像什么？
How does she do this? I have done that ponytail to myself. You have? Because I thought it was so genius. It is not that difficult to pull off. Really? And it looks really good. Well, I am crap with my own hair,
她是怎么做到的？我自己也做过那个马尾辫。你做过？因为我觉得它太天才了。要做到这一点并不难。真的吗？而且看起来真的很不错。好吧，我自己弄头发很烂，
so you might have to give me a tutorial. Well, guys, you should check it out if you're looking to spruce up your ponytail. Six minutes, 47 seconds. Fancy pony, fancy pony. Great ponytail. Well, you know the scene in the kitchen where Steve, as Michael, is eating a cup of noodles?
所以你可能得给我做一个教程。好吧，伙计们，如果你想美化你的马尾辫，你们应该看看。6分47秒。花哨的马尾，花哨的马尾。很棒的马尾辫。好吧，你知道厨房里史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔正在吃一杯面条的那一幕吗？
And he's confronting the group. He's trying to get us to feel guilty and or invite him to this party that he's not been invited to. John and I had a massive, massive laughing fit during this lunch scene. So much so you can see I'm eating some yogurt. So much so that I snorted the yogurt up into my nose, which... It's probably painful. It was a little burny, which then caused John
他正在质问大家。他试图让我们感到内疚，或者邀请他参加这个他没被邀请的派对。约翰和我在午餐这一幕中笑得非常厉害。以至于你可以看到我正在吃一些酸奶。以至于我把酸奶吸进了鼻子里，这……这可能很痛苦。有点灼烧感，这导致约翰
to laugh so hard that he was crying. And it was just the two of us. The two of us were having a moment where we could not get it together. You couldn't get it back. We couldn't. I don't know how they had any usable takes. I want you to know, I went and watched the season two bloopers.
笑得太厉害，以至于他哭了。只有我们两个。我们两个在那一刻无法控制自己。你无法恢复。我们不能。我不知道他们是怎么得到任何可用的镜头的。我想让你们知道，我去看过第二季的NG镜头。
You guys are on YouTube and it's really worth it. Can you see us losing it? There's bloopers of this scene and it is hilarious. I was cracking up watching you guys and also Brian does break in one of them too, but it's mostly you and John breaking, but the bloopers, the outtakes from this are fantastic. Oh my gosh, I have to watch those because that was just my memory.
你们在YouTube上，这真的很值得。你能看到我们失控吗？这一幕有NG镜头，非常搞笑。看着你们我笑得前仰后合，而且布莱恩在其中一个镜头里也笑场了，但主要是你和约翰笑场，但NG镜头，这些花絮太棒了。天哪，我必须看那些，因为那只是我的记忆。
I just remembered when I saw the scene how much John and I couldn't stop laughing. Okay, well look up season two, the office bloopers on YouTube, cause it's really funny. Also, did you notice that there is a community plate of Doritos? Yes. On a table on a paper plate. What's the story there? I don't know. Someone bought Doritos, put a paper plate in the middle of the table and then put the Doritos on the plate for us all to eat. I eat some, John eats some. What is that?
我看到那一幕时，只记得约翰和我笑得停不下来。好吧，在YouTube上搜索第二季办公室NG镜头，因为它真的很有趣。另外，你注意到有一盘公共的多力多滋吗？是的。放在桌子上的纸盘子里。那里有什么故事？我不知道。有人买了多力多滋，在桌子中间放了一个纸盘子，然后把多力多滋放在盘子里让我们大家吃。我吃了一些，约翰吃了一些。那是什么？
I think you guys just shared some Doritos. I don't think it's that complicated. Have you ever done that in an office? Like when you're eating lunch with people, you're like, hey guys, who wants to split some Doritos? Oh my gosh, Oscar and I shared snacks all the time, Jenna. We would get a bag of chips and we'd share, and we would get little paper cups
我想你们只是分享了一些多力多滋。我不认为这很复杂。你在办公室里做过那种事吗？就像当你和别人一起吃午饭时，你会说，嘿伙计们，谁想分一些多力多滋？天哪，奥斯卡和我一直分享零食，珍娜。我们会买一袋薯片然后分享，我们会拿小纸杯
and like split snacks into paper cups. We also like at least once a week would share a Coke. I can't tell you how many times I would walk over to my desk and Oscar would be like, there's half a Coke for you. I'd be like, thanks. And some chips. I think that I'm a person who always wants a full Coke and a full bag of chips. So I have not experienced this thing you're talking about.
然后把零食分到纸杯里。我们还至少每周分享一次可乐。我无法告诉你我走到办公桌前多少次，奥斯卡会说，有一半可乐给你。我会说，谢谢。还有一些薯片。我想我是一个总是想要一整瓶可乐和一整袋薯片的人。所以我没有经历过你说的这种事。
Well Oscar. This sharing of chips. So I have not experienced this thing you're talking about. Well Oscar- This sharing of snacks. Oscar Nunez and I shared snacks and sodas every single week. That is adorable. That is adorable. In fact, sometimes I know I'm like going on and on about this.
好吧，奥斯卡。这种分享薯片。所以我没有经历过你说的这种事。好吧，奥斯卡——这种分享零食。奥斯卡·努涅斯和我每周都分享零食和汽水。那太可爱了。那太可爱了。事实上，有时我知道我一直在说这个。
Sometimes one of us would get the Coke and start it, but the other wouldn't be ready. So we'd be like, I put the half Coke in the fridge for you. Be like, okay. So we would know, we'd sort of hide Coke in the fridge for you. I'd be like, OK. So we would know. We'd sort of hide it in the back. This is absolutely adorable. Meanwhile, I'm just over at my desk chugging my full Coke.
有时我们中的一个会买可乐并开始喝，但另一个还没准备好。所以我们会说，我把半瓶可乐放在冰箱里给你。会说，好的。所以我们会知道，我们会把可乐藏在冰箱里给你。我会说，好的。所以我们会知道。我们会把它藏在后面。这绝对太可爱了。与此同时，我只是在我的办公桌旁大口喝着我的一整瓶可乐。
Your full soda. I had a question for you about this scene. OK. At 7 minutes 48 seconds, Pam says, the professors would go to the parties. And Michael goes, yeah, they were the most fun. Jenna, how did you get through that line? I know you said you were laughing a lot, but like...
你的一整瓶汽水。我有一个关于这一幕的问题要问你。好的。在7分48秒，帕姆说，教授们会去参加派对。迈克尔说，是的，他们最有趣。珍娜，你是怎么完成那句台词的？我知道你说你笑了很多，但像……
I didn't get through any line in that scene. That line would be so hard for me to say because it's coming off of him being so ridiculous. Also, the whole time he's eating those dang noodles. So I just, it was, I have to go back. I want to watch the deleted. Well, what is it? The bloopers. You got to watch the bloopers. At eight minutes, two seconds, you guys, we find out what Jim thinks are the three ingredients
我在那一幕里没有完成任何台词。那句台词对我来说太难说了，因为它源于他太荒谬了。而且他一直在吃那些该死的面条。所以我只是，我必须回去。我想看删除的。好吧，那是什么？NG镜头。你必须看NG镜头。在8分2秒，伙计们，我们发现了吉姆认为的三个要素
for a great party. Number one, three cases of imported beer. Number two, karaoke machine. Number three, do not invite Michael. Yeah. I mean, he's probably not wrong. All right, at eight minutes, 25 seconds, Yeah. I mean, he's probably not wrong. All right. At eight minutes, 25 seconds, the camera crew helps Pam.
对于一个伟大的派对。第一，三箱进口啤酒。第二，卡拉OK机。第三，不要邀请迈克尔。是的。我是说，他可能没错。好吧，在8分25秒，是的。我是说，他可能没错。好吧。在8分25秒，摄像组帮助帕姆。
I know. The camera rushes over to her desk and indicates that she should look over to Dwight, who she discovers is eating a baby Ruth bar, the one that Angela bought. That's right. I have that you are in cahoots. In cahoots. Pam and the cameraman are in cahoots. So first, Pam takes the step of talking directly to the camera crew. And now the camera crew has gotten involved. That's a big deal. I'm surprised that we did this so early in the series
我知道。摄像机冲向她的办公桌，示意她应该看向德怀特，她发现他正在吃一根宝贝露丝棒，就是安吉拉买的那根。没错。我发现你们是同谋。同谋。帕姆和摄影师是同谋。所以首先，帕姆采取了直接与摄像组对话的步骤。现在摄像组也参与进来了。这是一件大事。我很惊讶我们在系列这么早的时候就做了这件事
when I was watching this. We're not that far in for us to be involving the crew like this. People should know that our camera operator was Randall Einhorn. He's also our DP. He went on to direct a bunch of episodes. And I had a really special relationship with Randall. And I remember filming the scene with him. He was really performing for me.
当我观看这一集时。我们还没走多远，就让摄制组参与进来。人们应该知道我们的摄像师是兰德尔·艾恩霍恩。他也是我们的摄影指导。他后来导演了很多集。我和兰德尔有一种非常特殊的关系。我记得和他拍摄那一幕。他真的在为我表演。
He would come over and he'd have a big smile on his face and a twinkle in his eye. And he would motion over. He would give me a little thumbs up. So all this interaction was happening. I felt like we were really performing together. And he was playing the character of the camera person. So I just have really fond memories of working with Randall in general
他会走过来，脸上带着灿烂的笑容，眼里闪烁着光芒。他会示意过来。他会给我一个大拇指。所以所有的互动都在发生。我觉得我们真的在一起表演。他在扮演摄像师的角色。所以我对和兰德尔一起工作有非常美好的回忆
when Pam would have really emotional scenes. Sometimes I would look at him and he would be teared up. No, he's got a big heart and he wears it on his sleeve and we all got really attached to Randall. I just think of him as sort of this very charming blue-eyed Terminator. Because you guys, you only ever see one of his eyeballs because the other eyeball is looking through the lens. So you see this one blue eye emoting emotion. And you're like, oh, you're like the friendly Terminator. The friendly Terminator.
当帕姆有非常感人的场景时。有时我会看着他，他会热泪盈眶。不，他有一颗宽广的心，他把心挂在袖子上，我们所有人都对兰德尔产生了深厚的感情。我只是把他看作是一个非常迷人的蓝眼睛终结者。因为伙计们，你只能看到他的一只眼球，因为另一只眼球正在通过镜头看。所以你看到这只蓝眼睛在表达情感。你会想，哦，你就像友好的终结者。友好的终结者。
At 9 minutes, 29 seconds, you guys, oh, Jim, you just break my heart all the time. But he's trying to be sly. He's trying to do that thing where he figures out, is Roy going to come? But he's trying to play it cool. So he's like, yeah, I just, you know, I just need a head count. Yeah. Is Roy going to be there tonight? You know why? It's just because I need to know how many burgers to make.
在9分29秒，伙计们，哦，吉姆，你总是让我心碎。但他试图变得狡猾。他试图做那种事情，弄清楚罗伊会来吗？但他试图保持冷静。所以他说，是的，我只是，你知道，我只是需要一个人数。是的。罗伊今晚会去吗？你知道为什么吗？那只是因为我需要知道要做多少汉堡。
Yeah. I mean, this is the subtext, right? It's nothing else. It's not because I love you and I want you to be in my apartment without your fiance. Yeah. Wait, is he? Yeah, he's still your fiance. He is. I know. It's hard to remember, right? Fan question from Juan Martinez. Was Roy really unable to attend the party or did Pam ditch him so she could hang out with Jim?
是的。我是说，这是潜台词，对吧？没有别的。不是因为我爱你，我想让你在没有未婚夫的情况下出现在我的公寓里。是的。等等，他是吗？是的，他还是你的未婚夫。他是。我知道。很难记住，对吧？来自胡安·马丁内斯的粉丝提问。罗伊是真的无法参加派对，还是帕姆甩了他，这样她就可以和吉姆在一起？
I don't think she ditched him and I don't think she lied to him. Yeah. I think Pam was just as excited that Roy couldn't attend as Jim is. Yeah, I think Roy probably has some dude hang out. He's very, he's kind of a dude dude, right? Yeah. And he probably has his thing. And also, Roy- Roy wouldn't wanna go.
我不认为她甩了他，也不认为她对他撒了谎。是的。我认为帕姆和吉姆一样兴奋，罗伊无法参加。是的，我想罗伊可能有一些男人的聚会。他是一个男人，对吧？是的。他可能有他的事情。而且，罗伊——罗伊不想去。
I was gonna say, the last thing Roy wants to do is hang out with any of the Dunder Mifflin employees. He's sorta over it. They have to do enough of that probably for him. So he was, I think, happy to sit this one out. And Pam was like, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God. And so was Jim. I'm like totally making this up.
我本来要说，罗伊最不想做的事就是和任何邓德·米夫林的员工混在一起。他有点受够了。他们可能已经为他做了足够多的那种事。所以他，我想，很高兴错过这一次。而帕姆当时想，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，哦，天哪。吉姆也是。我完全是编出来的。
But maybe Pam waited kind of till the last minute to tell Roy about the party so that it would be less likely that he could attend. Like I could see her maybe doing that. And I could see her downplaying it like, ugh, you know, I don't know. It's the thing I have to go to. Everyone's going.
但也许帕姆等到最后一刻才告诉罗伊关于派对的事，这样他参加的可能性就更小了。就像我能看到她也许会那样做。我能看到她轻描淡写地说，呃，你知道，我不知道。这是我必须去的事情。每个人都要去。
Yes. A hundred percent. It's going to be lame. You know what? If you don't want to go, you thing I have to go to. Everyone's going. Yes. 100%. It's going to be lame. You know what? If you don't want to go, you don't have to. Yeah, it's fine. I'll go because I feel like I have to, but I don't want you to have to totally change your plan. I totally get it. If you don't want to go, it's okay. This is 100% how that went down. I believe. Yes. All right. So now everyone's trying to get out of the office and they're trying to avoid Michael because they all know he's not invited. So people are making up excuses
是的。百分之百。这会很无聊。你知道吗？如果你不想去，我必须去的事情。每个人都要去。是的。100%。这会很无聊。你知道吗？如果你不想去，你不必去。是的，没关系。我会去，因为我觉得我必须去，但我不想让你必须完全改变你的计划。我完全明白。如果你不想去，没关系。这百分之百就是那样发生的。我相信。是的。好吧。所以现在每个人都试图离开办公室，他们试图避开迈克尔，因为他们都知道他没被邀请。所以人们在编造借口
to not hang out with him that night. And Angela, you have a great one. You say charity, bake, drive. Oh yeah, I'm sure my character's like horrible at lying. Horrible. Well, a lot of people wrote in to ask if our excuses were scripted or improvised. Angela, was yours scripted or improvised?
那天晚上不和他在一起。安吉拉，你有一个很棒的借口。你说慈善，烘焙，开车。哦，是的，我敢肯定我的角色在撒谎方面很糟糕。糟糕透顶。好吧，很多人写信来问我们的借口是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的。安吉拉，你的借口是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的？
Mine is a combo. So my scripted line was charity, bake, drive. And then Michael's scripted line was liar. And then Steve improvised, you are a liar. And then I improvised, no, I'm not, as I left. And I didn't even look back. And it stayed in. And I think it's great because that's exactly
我的是组合。所以我的剧本台词是慈善，烘焙，开车。然后迈克尔的剧本台词是骗子。然后史蒂夫即兴发挥，你是个骗子。然后我即兴发挥，不，我不是，当我离开时。我甚至没有回头。它保留了下来。我认为这很棒，因为那正是
how my character I think would have responded. Yes. I just love that Dwight says he has soccer and clarinet practice. Yes. And you know what I feel like I feel like sometimes I mean you know we have young children and sometimes when they're bad at lying they they just sort of list what their activities are so I sort of feel like, like Dwight probably growing up had clarinet and soccer practice and he just went to default. Also, as Dwight leaves, he says, see you Monday, Michael. Casual Friday tracker coming at you. No one's dressed casual. No, it's clearly a Friday because he says see you Monday. None of us are dressed casually, even though we're going to a barbecue after work. Well, people are going to change clothes.
我认为我的角色会做出的反应。是的。我只是喜欢德怀特说他有足球和单簧管练习。是的。你知道我感觉是什么吗？我觉得有时，我是说，你知道我们有年幼的孩子，有时当他们不擅长撒谎时，他们只是列出他们的活动是什么，所以我有点觉得，就像德怀特成长过程中可能有单簧管和足球练习，他只是默认了。另外，当德怀特离开时，他说，周一见，迈克尔。休闲星期五追踪器来了。没有人穿休闲装。不，这显然是星期五，因为他说周一见。我们都没有穿休闲装，尽管我们下班后要去烧烤。好吧，人们会换衣服的。
Don't you think they're going to go home and freshen up? I don't want to listen. It's still not casual Friday. I get it. I get it. We still set up in a previous episode that we have casual Fridays and yet here it is a Friday and none of us are dressed casually. No, you're right.
你不觉得他们会回家梳洗一下吗？我不想听。这仍然不是休闲星期五。我明白。我明白。我们在之前的一集里设定了我们有休闲星期五，然而现在是星期五，我们都没有穿休闲装。不，你是对的。
You're right. I'm going to stay on this. I think you stay on it. Don't worry, everybody. I'm on it. I'm on the mail cart. I'm on Casual Friday and we will continue to track Mindy's hair. Don't anyone lose sleep over it. We're on it. Oh, I am, as you know, obsessed with Mindy's hair. I'm obsessed. I have one thing to say before we go to the party.
你是对的。我会坚持这一点。我想你坚持住。别担心，大家。我在处理。我在邮件车上。我在休闲星期五上，我们将继续追踪敏迪的头发。不要让任何人为此失眠。我们在处理。哦，如你所知，我痴迷于敏迪的头发。我痴迷。在去派对之前我有一件事要说。
And again, this was like the, the sadique moment in the cold open for me. It's something I thought probably way too much about. Wouldn't Jim have known that Michael saw the Evite? This is the day he gets access to everyone's emails. Jim clearly sent it to everyone's work email. Yeah. Wouldn't he have known?
再一次，这对我来说就像冷开场中的萨迪克时刻。这是我想得可能太多的一件事。吉姆难道不知道迈克尔看到了电子邀请函吗？这是他获得每个人电子邮件权限的那一天。吉姆显然把它发到了每个人的工作邮箱。是的。他难道不知道吗？
He knows Michael knows, right? Well, he knows Michael knows by the way Michael is behaving. But you're saying as soon as he got access to the emails, the first thought Jim would have would be, oh, no. The e-vite's there. The e-vite's sitting in everyone's email. He's going to know. Well, similarly, how did we get all the way
他知道迈克尔知道，对吧？好吧，他通过迈克尔的行为方式知道迈克尔知道。但你是说一旦他获得电子邮件权限，吉姆想到的第一件事就是，哦，不。电子邀请函在那里。电子邀请函就在每个人的电子邮件里。他会知道的。好吧，同样地，我们是怎么一直走到
to the day of the party before Dwight thinks to mention the party to Michael? There's that scene where Dwight starts bringing up the party and Jim shushes him. And he's like, shh, no, no, no, don't say anything. You're telling me, I mean, when did he send out the e-fight? At least a week ago. In that whole week, he didn't have to like,
派对当天，德怀特才想到向迈克尔提起派对？有那一幕，德怀特开始提起派对，吉姆让他安静。他说，嘘，不，不，不，什么都别说。你在告诉我，我是说，他是什么时候发出电子邀请函的？至少一周前。在那整个星期里，他不需要像
keep the shush on Dwight. No, that didn't bump me as much because I feel like, I don't know. I know, I feel like, listen guys, this isn't all dudes, but I know from my experience with fellas, they probably aren't gonna think about the party till the day of, you know, they're not like, it's not like Dwight is like thinking about this party every
那样让德怀特安静。不，那并没有让我那么困扰，因为我觉得，我不知道。我知道，我觉得，听着伙计们，这不是所有男人，但我从我和男人的经历中知道，他们可能不会想到派对直到当天，你知道，他们不像，德怀特不像每天都在想这个派对。
day. He's got, you know, he's busy. He's busy. He's managing a secret relationship with Angela. Yeah, he's tracking yeast infections and Scranton. Yeah, he's got a lot going on. He's got a lot going on. All right, fair enough.
他有，你知道，他很忙。他很忙。他正在管理与安吉拉的秘密关系。是的，他正在追踪斯克兰顿的酵母菌感染。是的，他有很多事情要做。他有很多事情要做。好吧，有道理。
All right, guys, we're going to take a break. And when we come back, we're going to a party, a barbecue at Jim's house. We're going to tell you all about it. Ooh! Sick of dreaming smaller? Sick of investing but not seeing your money grow? Sick of feeling like you're leaving money on the table, paying high fees, and not knowing if you're even making the right investments? With Questrade, you get the right tools, stock insights, and proper guidance so you can become a better investor.
好吧，伙计们，我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们要去参加一个派对，在吉姆家举行的烧烤。我们要告诉你们所有关于它的事情。哦！厌倦了梦想更小？厌倦了投资却看不到你的钱增长？厌倦了感觉自己把钱留在桌子上，支付高额费用，却不知道自己是否做出了正确的投资？有了Questrade，你得到了正确的工具、股票见解和适当的指导，这样你就可以成为一个更好的投资者。
It's time to get the financial future you deserve. Get yours, Questrade. (*upbeat music*) Are you ready? You want to lay those out? Do you want to lay them out? I don't want to rush you. She's back. She got some food and the sass is back.
是时候获得你应得的财务未来了。得到你的，Questrade。（欢快的音乐）你准备好了吗？你想把它们摆出来吗？你想把它们摆出来吗？我不想催你。她回来了。她吃了一些食物，那种傲慢又回来了。
You guys, before we went to break, Jenna was getting a little lightheaded because she's really hungry. Yeah, so if you notice a tonal shift in this last part of the podcast, it's because we took an actual break during our break and we ate a full lunch. We ate, Jenna and I ate lunch together
伙计们，在我们休息之前，珍娜有点头晕，因为她真的很饿。是的，所以如果你注意到播客的最后一部分有语调变化，那是因为我们在休息期间确实休息了一下，我们吃了一顿完整的午餐。我们吃了，珍娜和我一起吃了午餐
and it kind of reminds me of how we had lunch every day on the set of The Office. I know. I love it so much. I was just talking to Lee last night where I said, well, he asked me a question. He was watching the episode with me and he said, "'What's it like for you to watch these episodes again?
这让我想起我们在《办公室》片场每天一起吃午餐的情景。我知道，我太喜欢了。昨晚我还在和李聊天，他问了我一个问题。他当时正和我一起看这一集，他问：“再次观看这些剧集对你来说是什么感觉？”
"'Does it bring you back?' And I said, it really, the flood of memories that come back to me and the most prevalent is how much we laughed together as a cast. And I said, and now I do this podcast with Angela and we laugh the same way when we do the podcast and when we edit the podcast and we eat lunch the same way. And now I'm tearing up because we just had one of our lunches. Yeah, that lunch in particular, Jenna. Was a good one. Was a good one, and it really reminded me, we navigated nine years of our lives,
“这会让你回想起过去吗？”我说，真的，涌上心头的回忆太多了，最深刻的就是我们作为演员在一起笑得有多开心。我说，现在我和安吉拉一起做这个播客，我们在录制和剪辑播客时，笑得和以前一模一样，吃午餐的方式也一样。现在我都要流泪了，因为我们刚刚才吃完一顿午餐。是的，珍娜，那顿午餐特别棒。真的很棒，它真的提醒了我，我们一起走过了九年的生活，
a lot happened to both of us, and we shared a lot at lunch. And some days it was just little tiny things, and then some days we had huge heart to hearts. And Jenna and I just now had a really pretty big heart to heart. Those lunches were like, sometimes they're like a therapy session. They're better than a therapy session because it's your BFF.
我们俩都经历了很多，在午餐时分享了很多。有时只是些琐碎小事，有时则是深入的交心。刚才我和珍娜进行了一次非常深入的交心。那些午餐就像是心理咨询。它们比心理咨询更好，因为那是你的闺蜜。
It's your BFF. That's right. All right. We're back guys. We're full of food. Okay. And I'm going to start with a fan question. Do it.
是你的闺蜜。没错。好了，伙计们，我们回来了。我们吃饱了。好的，我要从粉丝提问开始。来吧。
How about that from Rob Fish? Okay. He says, whose house was used for Jim's barbecue? Because that's right. We're go to this used for Jim's barbecue? Cause that's right. We're go to this barbecue at Jim's house. So for the house, we shot in a real neighborhood in Northern California. It wasn't a set and we had to have really unusual
罗伯·费什的那个问题怎么样？好的。他说，吉姆的烧烤派对是在谁家拍的？因为没错，我们去了吉姆家的烧烤派对。所以关于房子，我们是在北加州的一个真实社区拍摄的。那不是布景，我们不得不安排非常规的
shooting hours because it was a night shoot and there was really nighttime outside of the windows. So we usually would shoot from like 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. when we were shooting at Dunder Mifflin, but here we were really shooting more in the evening. Now, if they were shooting into the house, it didn't matter what was outside, they could black out the windows,
拍摄时间，因为那是夜间拍摄，窗外必须是真正的夜晚。我们在邓德·米夫林拍摄时通常是早上6点到下午6点，但在这里我们确实是在晚上拍摄。现在，如果他们是往房子里面拍，外面是什么并不重要，他们可以把窗户遮黑，
but for all those shots outside, it was really night. And some nights we stayed past 10 p.m. And do you remember we'd get a little bit tired? We would get a little loopy as of 9 p.m. And this was the first time where we shot offset, like really offset since the Dundee's. And we always had a lot of fun when we would do that. Yeah, and also I remember there wasn't really like
但对于所有外景镜头，那确实是夜晚。有些晚上我们待到了晚上10点以后。你还记得我们有点累了吗？到了晚上9点，我们就会变得有点神志不清。这是自“邓迪奖”以来，我们第一次在片场外拍摄，真的是在片场外。我们每次那样做都玩得很开心。是的，而且我还记得当时并没有
a place between scenes for you to go. No, I don't remember our trailers being there. No, I think they couldn't park them in the neighborhood. They were far away, so they would shuttle us in. And so in between scenes, we just really all hung out in that little living room, kind of. Totally. This leads me to a fan question by Rufio.
一个地方让你们在场景间休息。不，我不记得我们的房车在那里。不，我想他们没法把房车停在那个社区。它们离得很远，所以他们用班车接送我们。所以在场景之间，我们真的都待在那个小客厅里。完全是这样。这让我想到了鲁菲奥的一个粉丝提问。
He said, when you had to go to the bathroom, did you use the actual bathroom in the house or did you go off set? I don't remember. Because a lot of times you shoot in houses and they'll tape the toilet closed and put a little sign on it. And it says, do not use. And you have to go outside. They have like those porta potty things outside.
他说，当你们需要上厕所时，是用房子里真正的厕所，还是去片场外？我不记得了。因为很多时候你在房子里拍摄，他们会把马桶封住，贴个小牌子。上面写着“禁止使用”。你必须去外面。他们在外面放了那种移动厕所。
Or they'll rent the house next door and that becomes a holding area for everyone. Yeah, and maybe you can pee in the holding house. I peed in John and Jim's house. Oh no, I don't remember the toilet being taped shut. I remember them saying that I could go. And I like, you know, quickly I used, there was like a hall bathroom or something.
或者他们会租下隔壁的房子，作为大家的休息区。是的，也许你可以在那个休息用的房子里上厕所。我在约翰和吉姆的房子里上过厕所。哦不，我不记得马桶被封住了。我记得他们说我可以去。我记得我很快地用了一下，好像有个走廊厕所之类的。
Well, sometimes they would let cast members use the bathrooms in the house, but then they would have porta potties for the crew, which I always thought was kind of lousy. Well, I know one time it was explained to me by an AD because I was like, well, wait, where's the bathroom everyone's using? And she said to me that they could not afford for us to go too far away. Oh, that makes sense.
嗯，有时他们会让演员使用房子里的厕所，但会给剧组人员准备移动厕所，我一直觉得这有点糟糕。嗯，我知道有一次一位助理导演向我解释过，因为我当时问，等等，大家都在用哪个厕所？她告诉我，他们负担不起让我们走太远。哦，那说得通。
And so they often would have a bathroom for the actors a little bit closer, just purely because of timing. Yeah. So just know that so you don't feel as bad. So I don't feel so guilty. Yeah. But it's true, like you said, our actual trailers were probably a 15 minute van ride away. So they had to create a way for us to go to the bathroom.
所以他们通常会给演员准备一个近一点的厕所，纯粹是因为时间原因。是的。所以知道这一点，你就不会觉得那么糟糕了。所以我不用感到那么内疚了。是的。但这是真的，就像你说的，我们真正的房车可能要坐15分钟的货车才能到。所以他们必须为我们创造一个上厕所的方法。
That was a little closer to the set. All right, so when we all get to the party, Jim takes everyone on a tour of his house. Before we go on the tour, Tell me. There is something that I just love little things like this. Did you notice everyone's party attire? Wait, I, yes, I have that here too.
离片场近一点。好了，当我们都到达派对时，吉姆带大家参观了他的房子。在我们参观之前，告诉我。我就是喜欢这种小细节。你注意到大家的派对装束了吗？等等，是的，我这里也有。
Can we talk about everyone's casual clothes? Yes. Meredith is dressed like a biker gal with like a smoky eye. I have a whole card just for Meredith. Okay. Okay, she has a denim vest. She has a black V-neck,
我们可以聊聊大家的休闲装吗？是的。梅雷迪思打扮得像个机车女郎，还画了烟熏妆。我专门为梅雷迪思准备了一张卡片。好的。好的，她穿着一件牛仔背心。她穿着一件黑色V领衫，
shows a little bit of midriff. Yeah. Her hair is has a denim vest. She has a black v-neck, shows a little bit of midriff. Yeah. Her hair is half up, half down. Oh boy. She has some very dark smoky eyeliner and jeans. She looks a little bit like she's ready to go party. It is such a striking difference, I thought, of everybody's, the difference between everybody's casual outfit and their work outfit. The most striking is Meredith, for sure. Like, cause she wears like corduroy jumpers. Oh yeah, she wears like- To the office, she dresses kind of like a Raggedy Ann doll.
露出一小截腰部。是的。她的头发是一半扎起一半放下。天哪。她画了非常浓的烟熏眼线，穿着牛仔裤。她看起来有点像准备去派对狂欢。我觉得这和大家平时的休闲装与工作装之间的反差太强烈了。最引人注目的一定是梅雷迪思。因为她平时穿那种灯芯绒背带裤。哦对，她穿得像——去办公室时，她穿得像个破布娃娃。
She looks like she's in a potato sack and her hair down, but clearly party Meredith comes to play. She does. What about Kevin's hat? Oh, his black, is it like a fedora hat? What is that called? It's not a fedora, but it's like a, right? He looks like an old timey gangster
她看起来像套了个土豆袋，头发散着，但很明显，派对版的梅雷迪思是来玩的。确实。凯文的帽子呢？哦，他那顶黑色的，是软呢帽吗？那叫什么？那不是软呢帽，但就像是，对吧？他看起来像个老派黑帮
in like a 1920s movie, right? And he wears it all the time when he's in his band. Yeah, he does. Scrantonicity. Yeah, this is clearly, you know, casually, Kevin has his hat. His go-to look. And Kevin's fiance's there too.
就像20世纪20年代电影里的那样，对吧？他参加乐队时一直戴着它。是的，他戴着。Scrantonicity乐队。是的，这很明显，你知道，平时凯文就戴着他的帽子。他的招牌造型。凯文的未婚妻也在那儿。
Yes, a lot of people asked, who's the blonde woman at the party? Who's the blonde woman at the party? It's Stacy. Stacy. It's Kevin's fiance. And also, you notice Stanley's wife is there as well. She's the brunette woman sitting on the couch
是的，很多人问，派对上那个金发女人是谁？派对上那个金发女人是谁？那是斯泰西。斯泰西。那是凯文的未婚妻。而且你注意到斯坦利的妻子也在那儿。她是坐在沙发上的那个深色头发的女人，
next to Stanley. Yes. All right, what about the fact that Phyllis is still dressed in purple? Yes. She only wears plum, purple, lavender. She's very committed to that. What about the fact that Dwight has on Birkenstocks and says that he keeps an extra pair in his car? That's interesting. They look very new. I notice it's an important thing that we establish
坐在斯坦利旁边。是的。好了，菲利斯还穿着紫色衣服这件事呢？是的。她只穿李子色、紫色、薰衣草色。她对这些颜色非常执着。德怀特穿着勃肯鞋，还说他在车里放了一双备用的，这事儿怎么说？这很有趣。它们看起来很新。我注意到这是一个重要的点，我们确定了
the shoes that both you and Dwight are wearing in this episode. Later on, you're going to be at the barbecue with Jim and you're going to complain about getting sap on your shoe. I just have so much to complain about. I stepped in sap. I'm a vegetarian. But the whole reason they had to write the line that you stepped in sap is so that we
你和德怀特在这一集中穿的鞋子。稍后，你会和吉姆在烧烤派对上，你会抱怨鞋子上沾了树液。我有太多可以抱怨的了。我踩到了树液。我是个素食主义者。但他们必须写下你踩到树液这句台词的全部原因，是为了让我们
can pan down to your shoes because making sure we know what shoes you guys are each wearing is going to become very important later. It is. It is. Paul Feig said, are you ready to bump some Birkenstocks? Hey. Bumping Birkenstocks. That's right.
可以把镜头摇向你们的鞋子，因为确保我们知道你们每个人穿什么鞋，在后面会变得非常重要。确实是。确实是。保罗·费格说，准备好碰撞勃肯鞋了吗？嘿。碰撞勃肯鞋。没错。
All right. So I want to talk about Jim taking everyone on the tour of his house. Okay. He's so excited. Pam has arrived. She doesn't even have her coat off and he's ready to take her on this tour. And as they're walking down the hallway, first of all, just a side note,
好了。所以我想聊聊吉姆带大家参观他房子的事。好的。他太兴奋了。帕姆到了。她连外套都没脱，他就准备带她参观了。当他们走在走廊上时，首先，顺便提一下，
as they're walking down the hallway, Jim has a painted circular saw hanging on his wall. Mm-hmm, that's popular. I mean, my mom has a painted circular saw. My grandfather was really into that. And we have a few saws that are painted. Well, I, okay, I have seen the long saws painted, sort of like a long landscape,
当他们走在走廊上时，吉姆的墙上挂着一把画了画的圆锯。嗯，那很流行。我是说，我妈妈就有一把画了画的圆锯。我祖父真的很喜欢那个。我们有几把画了画的锯子。嗯，我，好吧，我见过那种长锯子画着画，有点像长长的风景画，
but I have so many questions about that. I have. Is that popular on the East Coast? Because, you know, being from Missouri and spending a lot of time in Lake Ozark, I've seen plenty of painted saws, but I just wasn't sure where Jim in Scranton, Pennsylvania got that item.
但我对那个有很多疑问。我有。那在东海岸很流行吗？因为，你知道，我来自密苏里州，在欧扎克湖度过了很多时间，我见过很多画了画的锯子，但我只是不确定吉姆在宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿是从哪儿弄到那个东西的。
Maybe it was a hand-me-down from a family member because I was given a painted circular saw. Okay. And I had it in my hallway. Okay. And I hung it in my hallway. Okay. And I hung it myself. I sort of like, I sort of balanced it on two nails. Yeah.
也许那是家庭成员传下来的，因为我就收到过一把画了画的圆锯。好的。我把它挂在走廊里。好的。我自己挂的。我有点，我把它平衡在两颗钉子上。是的。
And I had a friend who like was like kind of clumping through my hallway and it fell off. Oh dear. And they were like, are you trying to kill me? Cause I kinda, I didn't do a great job hanging it, but there you go. So yeah. I thought it was very go. So yeah, I saw that. I thought it was very interesting.
我有个朋友走过我的走廊时，它掉了下来。天哪。他们说，你是想杀了我吗？因为我挂得不太好，但就是这样。所以是的。我觉得这很有趣。
So you can check that out, people who like things in the background. So anyway, as they're walking up the steps after they've passed by the saw, Ryan asks if Katie is coming. And this is when we learn that Jim and Katie aren't dating anymore. He said, I haven't talked to her in a while.
所以你们可以去看看，喜欢背景细节的人。总之，当他们走上台阶，经过那把锯子后，瑞安问凯蒂会不会来。这时我们才知道吉姆和凯蒂不再约会了。他说，我有一阵子没跟她说话了。
I know. But fan question from Christina Velladotta, Ryan asked about Katie. Jim says he hasn't talked to her in a while. So it sounds like they've broken up, but then she's on Booze Cruise. Well, I think they're on again off again, because then Ryan in the same conversation says,
我知道。但克里斯蒂娜·维拉多塔的粉丝提问，瑞安问起凯蒂。吉姆说他有一阵子没跟她说话了。所以听起来他们分手了，但后来她又出现在了“酒醉游轮”那一集。嗯，我想他们是分分合合，因为后来瑞安在同一段对话中说，
do you mind if I ask her out? And Jim goes, maybe we won't talk about that right here. He says something like that. So he kind of skirts around the issue. To me, that answer is no, Ryan, don't call her. He didn't say, sure, man, go ahead. Well, when I heard him say that, I interpreted that as being him trying
你介意我约她出去吗？吉姆说，也许我们不在这里谈这个。他说了类似的话。所以他绕过了这个问题。对我来说，那个回答就是“不，瑞安，别给她打电话”。他没有说“当然，伙计，去吧”。嗯，当我听到他那么说时，我理解为他是在试图
to just protect Katie from Ryan. He might have. Not like I have such strong feelings for her that I don't want you to call her, but more like, um, I don't know. I read it as like, uh, yeah, I don't really know what's going on there and I don't really want to talk about it in front of Pam, but I certainly don't want you asking her out. Okay. I buy that. Okay. All right. So also here's another fan question, this time from Latamania, who we have heard from before. And by the way, I did look at Latamania's Insta page and she does amazing fan art of The Office. Oh, I'll check it out. So I'm just going to give a shout out guys, go check out
保护凯蒂不受瑞安骚扰。他可能是在保护她。不是说我对她有那么强烈的感情，不想让你约她，而是更像，嗯，我不知道。我解读为，嗯，我真的不知道那里发生了什么，我也不想在帕姆面前谈论它，但我肯定不想让你约她。好的。我接受这个说法。好的。好了。这里还有另一个粉丝提问，这次来自Latamania，我们之前听说过她。顺便说一下，我看了Latamania的Instagram页面，她画的《办公室》同人画太棒了。哦，我要去看看。所以我要给个大大的赞，伙计们，去看看
Latamania for some amazing office fan art. How do you spell that? Latamania. L-A-D-A-M-A-N-I-A. Okay, we'll check it out. Okay. She asked, why does Jim have two of the same poster in his place? This was such a good find. Okay, so around 13 minutes, 14 seconds, after the circular saw, they pass by just a pretty generic looking kind of framed poster picture on the wall. When they get up to Jim's bedroom, the same picture is
Latamania的精彩《办公室》同人画。那个怎么拼？Latamania。L-A-D-A-M-A-N-I-A。好的，我们会去看看。好的。她问，为什么吉姆家里有两张一样的海报？这个发现太棒了。好的，在13分14秒左右，经过圆锯后，他们经过墙上一张看起来很普通的带框海报。当他们走到吉姆的卧室时，同一张画
hanging above one of his bookshelves. Clearly, as we've mentioned, we were on a budget and we ran out of decor. I think they just moved it when they shot it. They moved it! I think they moved it, which I think is very very funny. There might have been something on the wall they needed to cover. Okay, so at this point in the show, we cut from the party back to- The improv class.
挂在他的书架上方。很明显，正如我们提到的，我们预算有限，装饰品用完了。我想他们拍摄时只是把它挪了个位置。他们挪了它！我想他们挪了它，我觉得这非常非常有趣。墙上可能有什么东西需要遮盖。好的，在这一集此时，我们从派对切回了——即兴表演课。
Yes, and we're gonna see Michael in the improv class for the first time. It's real, he wasn't lying. He really has to go to his improv class. And this is when you find out that Michael just gets out a gun and shoots everybody in every scene he does. Yeah. It's brilliant.
是的，我们要第一次看到迈克尔上即兴表演课。这是真的，他没撒谎。他真的得去上他的即兴表演课。这时你发现迈克尔在每一场戏里都会掏出一把枪，把所有人都射杀。是的。太天才了。
He's the worst. He's the worst person to improvise with. And he thinks he's hilarious. And the scene when the teacher says, "'Michael, I want you to give me all the guns you have.'" Yeah. Is so great. I tried to reach out to Michael Naughton
他是最糟糕的。他是最不适合一起即兴表演的人。而且他觉得他自己搞笑极了。当老师说“迈克尔，我要你交出你所有的枪”时，那场戏。是的。太棒了。我试着联系迈克尔·诺顿，
because I did a sketch show with him years ago called Balls Out. Amazing. And he is such a funny guy. And he played the teacher, right? He played the teacher, Chris. He performs at the Groundlings. You can see him there if you're in Los Angeles.
因为几年前我和他一起做过一个短剧节目叫《Balls Out》。太棒了。他是个非常有趣的人。他演了那个老师，对吧？他演了老师，克里斯。他在Groundlings剧团表演。如果你在洛杉矶，可以在那里看到他。
He's also done tons of episodes of Always Sunny in Philadelphia. Oh yeah. So you might recognize him from other things. He's a hilarious actor, but he's currently main stage company at the Groundlings as well. I wonder if people at home understand the genius satire of this improv class.
他还演过很多集《费城永远阳光灿烂》。哦，是的。所以你可能会从其他作品中认出他。他是个搞笑的演员，但他目前也是Groundlings剧团的主演公司成员。我不知道家里看的人是否理解这个即兴表演课的讽刺天才之处。
As an improviser, were you just dying when you were watching this? I wanted to be in the improv class. I know it wouldn't track for my character, but I was like, oh. I knew a bunch of those people and they're such funny, funny people. Now we go back to the party for the scene. The scene. Pam is alone in Jim's bedroom. I have so much to say about this because the preparation
作为一个即兴表演者，你看的时候是不是快笑死了？我想参加那个即兴表演课。我知道这不符合我角色的设定，但我当时想，哦。我认识那些人中的很多，他们是非常非常有趣的人。现在我们回到派对场景。那场戏。帕姆独自在吉姆的卧室里。关于这一点我有太多话要说，因为任何有吉姆和帕姆的戏份，
that went in to any scene with Jim and Pam, it would bring production to a halt. It really would. They were so concerned about getting these scenes right. When Jim and I would have to get in a fight, or if we had to have these moments up on the roof in this bedroom, and we would spend so much time on these. It's true. As a cast member- I'm so sorry.
准备工作都会让制作停滞。真的会。他们非常关心要把这些戏拍好。当吉姆和我必须吵架，或者我们必须在屋顶或这个卧室里有这些时刻时，我们会花很多时间在上面。这是真的。作为演员——我很抱歉。
When we would see that there was a big pivotal Jim and Pam scene, we'd be like, oh God, are you before it or after it? Oh no. I feel like Phyllis would bring in all of her bills to pay. She'd be like, I'm bringing, I need stuff to do. Buckle in. We're gonna be here a while. Because they're gonna just really indulge.
当我们看到有一场吉姆和帕姆的关键大戏时，我们会说，哦天哪，你是排在它前面还是后面？哦不。我觉得菲利斯会带上她所有的账单来付。她会说，我带了，我需要找点事做。系好安全带。我们要在这儿待一会儿了。因为他们真的会沉浸其中。
Once I became a mom, I didn't mind it. When I saw you guys had a big scene, I'd be like, Ooh, that means I'm going to go visit my daughter at preschool. Yeah. You'd be like, can I leave? Can I come back? I have a three hour break. Well, just know that it was always so important to us
一旦我当了妈妈，我就不介意了。当我看到你们有大戏时，我会说，噢，那意味着我可以去幼儿园看我女儿了。是的。你会说，我可以离开吗？我可以回来吗？我有三个小时的休息时间。嗯，要知道，这对我们来说总是非常重要的，
to get it right. And I remember having long conversations about this scene. So the words that are written in the scene are of no importance. We discussed that what was important was everything we're not saying, the subtext of the scene. This is all about Pam being in Jim's bedroom and sitting on his bed. We had to make sure that we very naturally found a way for Pam to sit on his bed,
要把它拍好。我记得关于这场戏我们进行了很长时间的对话。所以戏里写的台词并不重要。我们讨论过，重要的是我们没说出口的一切，即这场戏的潜台词。这一切都是关于帕姆在吉姆的卧室里，坐在他的床上。我们必须确保帕姆能非常自然地找到坐上他床的方法，
and she couldn't just walk in the room and sit on the bed. So she had to start by sitting on his night table. And then we had to put the yearbook in exactly the right place so that when she went to grab it she would most naturally then sit on his bed. And as I was watching this it brought me back to all of those moments early on in dating and in college or whatever when you walk into that person's bedroom for the first time. And you've thought about it for a long time.
她不能只是走进房间就坐到床上。所以她必须先从坐在他的床头柜上开始。然后我们必须把年鉴放在完全正确的位置，这样当她去拿它时，她就会最自然地坐到他的床上。当我看着这一幕时，它让我想起了早年约会时，或者大学里，或者无论什么时候，你第一次走进那个人的卧室的所有时刻。你已经想了很久了。
You've thought about it like, where do they sleep? What does that look like? This is their most intimate room in their house. And John is so perfect. If you notice, as soon as Pam sits down on the bed, John starts shifting in his desk chair. And he looks at her and he immediately looks away. Like the fact that she's just sat on his bed,
你一直在想，他们睡在哪里？那看起来是什么样子的？这是他们家里最私密的房间。约翰太完美了。如果你注意看，帕姆一坐到床上，约翰就开始在办公椅上挪动。他看着她，然后立刻移开了视线。就像她坐在他床上这件事，
it's almost too much for him. Not only is this woman he's in love with in his room, but now she is in this intimate place where she's sitting across from him on his bed as he's probably hoped and thought about for a long, long time. And here's what I love about our show, and I think that this is why people are in love with Jim and Pam and why they respond to them so well is because a lot of times in movies and television shows when people quote unquote fall in love or you have a couple that is going to fall in love, it seems to kind of be like a lot about sex, right? Like they meet at a bar and then they burst through the door ripping each other's clothes off. and then they burst through the door, ripping each other's clothes off.
对他来说几乎难以承受。不仅是他爱着的这个女人在他的房间里，而且现在她正处于这个私密的地方，坐在他对面的床上，正如他可能已经期待和思考了很久很久的那样。这就是我喜欢我们剧的原因，我认为这就是为什么人们爱上吉姆和帕姆，以及为什么他们对他们反应如此强烈的原因，因为很多时候在电影和电视节目中，当人们所谓的“坠入爱河”或者有一对即将坠入爱河的情侣时，看起来好像很多都是关于性的，对吧？就像他们在酒吧相遇，然后冲进门，撕掉对方的衣服。然后他们冲进门，撕掉对方的衣服。
That never happens really, right? Like that's not really real. Jim and Pam, this moment of them just being in this bedroom, not kissing, not touching, not talking about this stolen moment is more romantic and sexy than that burst through the door, ripping each other's clothes off in my opinion. Well, the stakes are so high and that's real life.
那从来不会真正发生，对吧？那不是真的。吉姆和帕姆，他们只是待在这个卧室里的这一刻，没有接吻，没有触碰，没有谈论这个偷来的时刻，在我看来比那种冲进门、撕掉对方衣服的戏码更浪漫、更性感。嗯，赌注太高了，这就是现实生活。
When you really like someone, it's like you can feel your heart beating out of your chest the first time you see a part of them that you've wondered about. Their space and where they live. Well, I wrote to break up this beautiful moment. Please. When Pam is looking at Jim's yearbook while sitting on his bed, Jim gazes lovingly at her. In this moment, you can see my character's purse on the bed. What? My character always carried this
当你真正喜欢某人时，就像你第一次看到你一直好奇的他们的一部分时，你能感觉到心脏在胸腔里跳动。他们的空间和他们住的地方。嗯，我写下来是为了打破这个美丽的时刻。请。当帕姆坐在床上看吉姆的年鉴时，吉姆深情地注视着她。在这一刻，你可以看到我角色的钱包在床上。什么？我的角色总是带着这个
little black clutch, you know, and it's there on the bed with like a coat. That's what I love too. It's like, it's that thing, you go into someone's house when you're in college or even in your 20s starting out, you're like, oh, you know, you go to a party. There's that one guest room or someone's throw your coat on the bed. Where you throw your coat.
小黑手包，你知道，它就在床上，还有一件外套。这也是我喜欢的。就是那种感觉，当你上大学或者甚至20多岁刚开始时，你去别人家，你去参加派对。有那个客房，或者有人把外套扔在床上。你把外套扔在那儿。
There's some coats in my purse. I thought it was such a nice touch. I, oh, I love that. Look for the little black clutch. That's my purse, Angela Martin's purse. That's a nice touch. Oh, I love that. Look at the little black clutch. That's my purse, Angela Martin's purse. That's a great detail. Well, I remember in addition to the scene, they spent a lot of time planning Jim's bedroom because it was going to be very revealing.
我的钱包里有一些外套。我觉得这是一个很好的细节。我，噢，我喜欢那个。找找那个小黑手包。那是我的钱包，安吉拉·马丁的钱包。那是个很好的细节。噢，我喜欢那个。看看那个小黑手包。那是我的钱包，安吉拉·马丁的钱包。那是个很棒的细节。嗯，我记得除了这场戏，他们花了很多时间设计吉姆的卧室，因为它会非常具有揭示性。
And so our set decorator, Michael Gallenberg, he's our set designer, he was in charge of decorating this room under the direction of Paul Feig and Greg Daniels and Jen Solotta who wrote the episode. Fan question, Ricky Caden or Cadden and Zach McCutcheon both wrote in separately, how much of the stuff in Jim's room was actually John Krasinski's? None, none, except fan question from Lulu, Katrina,
所以我们的布景师，迈克尔·加伦伯格，他是我们的布景设计师，他在保罗·费格、格雷格·丹尼尔斯和写这一集的简·索洛塔的指导下负责装饰这个房间。粉丝提问，瑞奇·卡登和扎克·麦卡琴都分别写信问，吉姆房间里的东西有多少是约翰·卡拉辛斯基自己的？没有，没有，除了粉丝提问来自露露、卡特里娜、
Michael Kemper and many others, was that really John Krasinski's yearbook photo? Yes. Yes. Not his yearbook. They made a fake yearbook page where they superimposed his actual yearbook photo. But there's a lot of interesting stuff in that room. All right, background folks. There's a lot of wonderful little nuggets in Jim's room.
迈克尔·肯珀和许多其他人，那真的是约翰·卡拉辛斯基的年鉴照片吗？是的。是的。不是他的年鉴。他们做了一个假的年鉴页面，把他的真实年鉴照片叠加了上去。但那个房间里有很多有趣的东西。好了，背景人员。吉姆的房间里有很多美妙的小彩蛋。
I'm sure you noticed. I know I'm probably going to have missed some, but here are some. He has a guitar. Of course he does. Okay, of course he does. But why of course? Have we ever seen him play a guitar? I don't know, but I feel like all the guys that I thought were cool in my 20s had a guitar that they, I get that. That they hardly even played. Well, a fan, Kelsey VZ7, pointed out that in a later episode, you know when Jim is playing Second Life,
我相信你们注意到了。我知道我可能漏掉了一些，但这里有一些。他有一把吉他。他当然有。好的，他当然有。但为什么是“当然”？我们见过他弹吉他吗？我不知道，但我感觉我20多岁时觉得酷的所有男生都有一把吉他，他们，我懂那个。他们几乎都不怎么弹。嗯，一位粉丝，Kelsey VZ7，指出在后来的一集中，你知道吉姆在玩《第二人生》时，
his avatar has a guitar slung over his shoulder. So there's something in Jim that either wishes he played guitar or... Thought it was cool to play or... But we never see him play it, right? No. Correct us guys if we're wrong. I don't think we ever see Jim bust out a guitar.
他的化身肩膀上背着一把吉他。所以吉姆内心深处要么希望自己会弹吉他，要么……觉得弹吉他很酷，或者……但我们从没见过他弹，对吧？没有。如果我们错了，请纠正我们。我不认为我们见过吉姆拿出吉他。
He never takes the stage with Scrantonicity. No. No. There's a lava lamp. There's the favor poster. On his bulletin board, I want you to know, we hadn't even released an episode yet. A fan wrote in to me and said, look at Jim's bulletin board. Is that a voodoo doll of Roy?
他从没和Scrantonicity乐队一起登台。没有。没有。有一个熔岩灯。有那张海报。在他的公告板上，我想让你们知道，我们甚至还没播出这一集。一位粉丝写信给我说，看看吉姆的公告板。那是罗伊的巫毒娃娃吗？
Yes, he has a doll. Hanging. By a noose. In what looks like a warehouse shirt. This is crazy. Yeah. Yeah. It's, yeah. warehouse shirt. This is crazy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
是的，他有一个娃娃。挂着。用绳套。穿着看起来像仓库员工的衬衫。这太疯狂了。是的。是的。仓库衬衫。这太疯狂了。是的。是的。是的。
We had another fan write in, Alston Brown, who said, was Jim the Scranton Strangler? This was perhaps evidence. Yes. What is that? Now listen, I reached out to Michael Gallenberg to ask him about that. He's on vacation.
我们有另一位粉丝写信，奥尔斯顿·布朗，他说，吉姆是斯克兰顿勒杀手吗？这也许是证据。是的。那是什么？现在听着，我联系了迈克尔·加伦伯格问他这件事。他在度假。
He's on vacation. Well, we'll have to get it as a follow-up question. We will, because I would love to find out who put that on the cork board. Yeah, well, we'll have to put that in our candy bag. Yeah. Also, there's like some kind of sketch of a motorcycle. It looks like a printout, like what does Jim?
他在度假。嗯，我们得把它作为一个后续问题。我们会问的，因为我很想知道是谁把它放在软木板上的。是的，嗯，我们得把它放进我们的糖果袋里。是的。还有，有一个摩托车的草图。看起来像打印出来的，吉姆到底是什么？
Jim is starting sound a little bit like a cliche. He has a guitar, he has maybe a motorcycle he wants, who knows? There's also, it looks like a card. It says son, like maybe his parents. I know, did you see that? It was so sweet. There's some photos.
吉姆开始听起来有点像个陈词滥调。他有吉他，他可能想要一辆摩托车，谁知道呢？还有一个看起来像卡片的东西。上面写着“儿子”，就像他父母给的。我知道，你看到了吗？太甜了。有一些照片。
There's a little like plaque that says making sense. What? There's a penguin on his desk. I do love when you pan across over to Pam, you see his CD player. These are the tech moments that kind of date us. And then he does take work home a little bit because there's a Dunder Mifflin catalog on his desk.
有一个小牌子写着“Making Sense”（有意义）。什么？他的桌子上有一只企鹅。我确实喜欢当你把镜头摇向帕姆时，你看到他的CD播放机。这些是让我们显得有点过时的科技时刻。然后他确实带了一点工作回家，因为他的桌子上有一本邓德·米夫林的产品目录。
Wow, that's good stuff. And I'm sure there's more I miss, so you guys write in. So now we go back downstairs to the party. Party's going, everyone's having beer. Now, Omi, who played the IT guy who's also at the party, he gave an interview where he said that we were drinking real beer. I don't remember that and I wrote it on a card, Jenna. I did not drink real beer. I didn't either. Well, I hate beer, so I had a beer bottle filled with water. I don't remember that either. Yeah, I don't remember any real beer.
哇，那真是好东西。我相信还有更多我漏掉的，所以你们写信告诉我们。现在我们回到楼下的派对。派对正在进行，大家都在喝啤酒。现在，奥米，那个演IT男的演员也在派对上，他接受采访时说我们喝的是真啤酒。我不记得那个了，我把它写在卡片上了，珍娜。我没喝真啤酒。我也没有。嗯，我讨厌啤酒，所以我拿了一个装满水的啤酒瓶。我也不记得那个了。是的，我不记得有任何真啤酒。
filled with water. I don't remember that either. Yeah, I don't remember any real beer. No, that feels like it would be unusual for our group. Yeah. They weren't that kind of group. I had water. I know that. Okay. In my beer. All right. And that's why I said, well, Jesus drank wine. You know, I'm sort of trying to justify it, I guess. But mine was water. Yeah. He did also say in the same interview that they were playing the Xbox 360 and it had games that hadn't been released yet. I remember that. The guys were so excited. They were so excited. That I do remember, but the beer, I don't remember.
装满水。我也不记得那个了。是的，我不记得有任何真啤酒。不，那感觉对我们剧组来说很不寻常。是的。他们不是那种剧组。我喝的是水。我知道这一点。好的。在我的啤酒里。好了。这就是为什么我说，嗯，耶稣喝葡萄酒。你知道，我是在试图证明它的合理性，我想。但我的那是水。是的。他在同一次采访中还说，他们当时在玩Xbox 360，里面有还没发布的游戏。我记得那个。男孩子们太兴奋了。他们太兴奋了。那个我记得，但啤酒，我不记得。
Okay, did you notice in the kitchen scene with Kelly, Oscar, and Stanley, where they're talking about paper, I can see it. Kelly's hair is half up, half down. But she's still in a paisley top. But she is more Mindy. She's like. Oh, she's 100% Mindy.
好的，你注意到在厨房里凯利、奥斯卡和斯坦利谈论纸张的那场戏了吗？我能看到。凯利的头发是一半扎起一半放下。但她还穿着那件佩斯利花纹的上衣。但她更像敏迪了。她就像。哦，她100%是敏迪。
She's now fully Mindy. But she is. Her wardrobe hasn't caught up. OK, I feel like at this point, her hair has become unfussed. It's, you know, we're not doing that anymore. But now I kind of want to start tracking her wardrobe. OK, Jenna. OK, because I feel like the hair has come down
她现在完全是敏迪了。但她是。她的衣着还没跟上。好的，我觉得此时她的头发已经变得随意了。它，你知道，我们不再那样做了。但现在我有点想开始追踪她的衣着了。好的，珍娜。好的，因为我觉得头发已经散下来
now enough times, I wanna see when the wardrobe changes. There is also a scene during the party that I love because it's just one of these things I love about our show. What? Is a runner. I love a runner that carries over multiple episodes for many years and Kevin calls Ryan fire guy. Yes. You know, and I just love that. It's
足够多次了，我想看看衣着什么时候改变。派对期间还有一场戏我非常喜欢，因为这只是我喜欢我们剧的那些事情之一。什么？是一个贯穿全剧的梗。我喜欢一个贯穿多集、持续多年的梗，凯文叫瑞安“火男”。是的。你知道，我就是喜欢那个。它
stuck. I like that too. So when the karaoke machine gets going, Phyllis is singing karaoke. It was so sweet. Phyllis was so charming. Do you remember filming that? I do. And I wrote about it in my journal. You really journaled hard on this episode. This was a big journal episode for me. I guess so. Okay, I wrote this. Oh my gosh, when Phyllis had to do the karaoke scene, we were all losing it. We started laughing so hard.
深入人心。我也喜欢那个。所以当卡拉OK机开始运作时，菲利斯在唱卡拉OK。太甜了。菲利斯太迷人了。你记得拍摄那场戏吗？我记得。我把它写在我的日记里了。你在这集里真的写了很多日记。这对我是重要的一集日记。我想是吧。好的，我写了这个。天哪，当菲利斯不得不做卡拉OK那场戏时，我们都快疯了。我们开始笑得太厉害了。
First of all, she had to sing White Snakes, Here I Go Again, and she had never even heard of White Snake. Oh my gosh. The production staff got her a copy of the song and she walked around for days listening to it and practicing. She was so cute and she was really nervous, but I thought she was brilliant. That is amazing.
首先，她得唱白蛇乐队的《Here I Go Again》，她甚至从来没听说过白蛇乐队。天哪。制作组给了她一份歌词，她走了好几天，一直在听，一直在练习。她太可爱了，她真的很紧张，但我认为她表现得太棒了。那太神奇了。
I love this image of Phyllis walking around listening to White Snake. Incidentally, that album was the first record album I ever bought, like actual record album as a teenager was White Snake and I would listen to it all the time. My first tape cassette I ever bought was REO Speedwagon. Oh. Heard it from a friend who, heard it from a friend who, heard it from another you've been messing around.
我喜欢菲利斯走来走去听白蛇乐队的画面。顺便说一下，那张专辑是我买的第一张唱片，作为青少年时买的真正的唱片就是白蛇乐队的，我一直都在听。我买的第一盘磁带是REO Speedwagon乐队的。《Heard it from a friend who, heard it from a friend who, heard it from another you've been messing around》。
Okay we can't sing anymore. Okay we can't sing, we can't pay for that. Also, no one wants to hear that. Also, no one wants to hear that, but imagine sweet, adorable Phyllis walking around. Here I go again on my own. With like a headset on. Well, do you remember that music video?
好的，我们不能再唱了。好的，我们不能唱，我们付不起版权费。而且，没人想听那个。而且，没人想听那个，但想象一下甜美、可爱的菲利斯走来走去。《Here I go again on my own》。戴着耳机。嗯，你记得那个音乐录影带吗？
Oh. With the tawny, tawny, was her name. All over the hood of the car. The redheaded lady just crazy. She did the splits. On a car. Car. On a muscle car. All over the hood of the car. The redheaded lady, just crazy. She did the splits. On a car. Car. On a muscle car.
噢。那个叫托妮的女人。就在车盖上。那个红头发的女人简直疯了。她劈叉。在车上。车。在肌肉车上。就在车盖上。那个红头发的女人，简直疯了。她劈叉。在车上。车。在肌肉车上。
In a dress. Yeah. Okay, you know what? No judgment. Feel yourself. Do it. Now, tell me, when do you go outside with Dwight? There's a moment where I slip outside, no one notices.
穿着裙子。是的。好的，你知道吗？不予置评。做你自己。来吧。现在，告诉我，你什么时候和德怀特出去的？有一个时刻我溜了出去，没人注意到。
And then if you're watching the scene inside, I'm in it on the couch. Yeah. Right? Well, when Michael crashes the party, you're inside. I'm inside. That's right. And then all of a sudden, as the party gets going,
然后如果你看里面的场景，我在沙发上。是的，对吧？嗯，当迈克尔闯入派对时，你在里面。我在里面。没错。然后突然之间，当派对开始时，
you don't see me or Dwight. Well, this is what's a little curious for me, because Michael crashes the party and you're inside and then he starts singing Islands in the Stream, a duet, Jim saves him which is very charming and then I just need to point out by the way Steve starts to harmonize like real well I know that song I know it's really pretty great but I also want to point out that when he crashes the party, Jim and Pam are always sitting next to each other at the party.
你看不到我或德怀特。嗯，这对我来说有点好奇，因为迈克尔闯入派对，你在里面，然后他开始唱《Islands in the Stream》，一首二重唱，吉姆救了他，这非常迷人，然后我只是需要指出，顺便说一下，史蒂夫开始和谐地唱得非常好，我知道那首歌，我知道，真的很棒，但我也想指出，当他闯入派对时，吉姆和帕姆在派对上总是坐在一起。
If you track us, we're on some chairs, then we're on the couch together. We are making sure to maximize this party for like maximum next to each other time. You're sitting next to each other. The other thing I noticed throughout the party is that Jim's roommate and his girlfriend are all over each other.
如果你追踪我们，我们在一些椅子上，然后我们在沙发上坐在一起。我们确保最大限度地利用这个派对，尽可能多地待在一起。你们坐在一起。我注意到的另一件事是，在整个派对中，吉姆的室友和他的女朋友一直黏在一起。
They're constantly making out. They're making out or she's sitting on his lap or she has a leg like over his leg. And to say those two people did not know each other before they started filming. And I mean, what is that job? How do you get, I mean, I would feel so shy if I was, that was my job.
他们一直在亲热。他们要么在亲热，要么她坐在他腿上，或者她的一条腿搭在他腿上。要说那两个人拍戏前根本不认识。我是说，那是什么工作？你怎么能，我是说，如果那是我的工作，我会觉得很害羞。
I was like, hi, nice to meet you. I guess we're just gonna Hang on to each other all day day for tonight while we shoot this thing. Back to the scene. Steve and John, as Jim and Michael are harmonizing islands in the stream. And then in the background, we go over their shoulder and we slowly push in on Angela's feet and Dwight's feet bumping the Birkenstocks.
我当时想，嗨，很高兴见到你。我想我们今天晚上拍摄时就得一直黏在一起了。回到场景。史蒂夫和约翰，当吉姆和迈克尔和谐地唱着《Islands in the Stream》时。然后背景里，我们越过他们的肩膀，慢慢推向安吉拉的脚和德怀特的脚，碰撞着勃肯鞋。
All right, let's break down this scene for a second. I have to tell you some behind the scenes. Okay, I have some fan questions as well. Well, ask them. Perhaps they'll lead you in. Maybe they're part of my note cards. Well, this is not a fan question. This is a me question.
好了，让我们分析一下这场戏。我得告诉你一些幕后花絮。好的，我也有一些粉丝提问。嗯，问吧。也许它们会引导你。也许它们是我卡片的一部分。嗯，这不是粉丝提问。这是我的问题。
What are you in? Is it a shed? Is it a dog house? It seems too small to be a shed and too large to be a doghouse. What is it? It looked like a giant dollhouse that people would buy for their little girl. There was like a ramp of steps that went up to it. It looked like someone had bought this for their little girl to play in, like a fancy dollhouse. Yeah. Well, Angela, I have a fan question now. A-Town and Nat Attack and Brooklyn Jade
你在什么里面？是棚子吗？是狗屋吗？它看起来太小而不像棚子，太大而不像狗屋。那是什么？它看起来像人们会给小女孩买的巨大玩具屋。有一道斜坡台阶通向它。看起来有人给他们的小女孩买了这个来玩，像个豪华玩具屋。是的。嗯，安吉拉，我现在有个粉丝提问。A-Town、Nat Attack和Brooklyn Jade
all want to know, was that really Rain and Angela making out or were they just random stunt people wearing the same shoes? And if it was them, did they talk? How did they make it not weird? I mean, yeah, I think we all just want to know. How did that go down? All right. Okay. So of course it's weird. It's totally weird. It was rain and I, we did not kiss guys. We did not make out. In fact, it was really cold out in that dollhouse. So I had on a big thick coat.
都想知道，那真的是雷恩和安吉拉在亲热，还是只是穿着同样鞋子的替身演员？如果是他们，他们说话了吗？他们是怎么做到不尴尬的？我是说，是的，我想我们都想知道。那是怎么发生的？好的。好的。所以当然很尴尬。完全尴尬。那是雷恩和我，我们没有接吻，伙计们。我们没有亲热。事实上，那个玩具屋里真的很冷。所以我穿了一件厚外套。
I had hand warmers, but they did want to see our Birkenstocks a bump in. It was a little tricky because we had to time it out perfectly and we tried different positions of our feet. Here's the thing, Rainn Wilson is 6'3". I am 5'1". So my feet did not hang out of the dollhouse. Oh my gosh. Yeah, if your bodies were positioned so that you could actually be kissing one another, we would never see your feet.
我有暖手宝，但他们确实想看到我们的勃肯鞋碰撞。这有点棘手，因为我们必须完美地把握时间，我们尝试了不同的脚部位置。事情是这样的，雷恩·威尔逊身高6英尺3英寸。我身高5英尺1英寸。所以我的脚没有挂在玩具屋外面。天哪。是的，如果你们的身体位置是为了让你们真的能亲吻对方，我们就永远看不到你们的脚了。
No, no. So we tried our feet in a few different positions so the camera could see them both. We were laying side by side, kind of flipping our feet back and forth. And Paul Feig was like, you guys kind of look like you're doing a sad breaststroke swim or something. He was like, I don't know what you're doing.
不，不。所以我们尝试了几个不同的脚部位置，这样摄像机就能同时看到它们。我们并排躺着，有点来回翻动我们的脚。保罗·费格说，你们看起来有点像在做悲伤的蛙泳或者什么的。他说，我不知道你们在做什么。
It looks like you're swimming. So he was like, all right, how do I say this? This is somewhat awkward Angela, but I think you need to lay on your back and straddle rain. I was like, what? And he said, yeah, he said, I'd love to see your little feet wrap around his calves and rub back and forth.
看起来像在游泳。所以他说，好吧，我该怎么说呢？这有点尴尬，安吉拉，但我认为你需要仰面躺着，跨在雷恩身上。我当时想，什么？他说，是的，他说，我很想看到你那双小脚缠在他的小腿上，来回摩擦。
So in order for me to do this, you guys, my face was in his chest for you to see my feet. Were you like suffocating? Kind of. I'm imagining like, how are you breathing? Rain was also doing sort of like this painful kind of plank move. So that he didn't crush you?
所以为了让我做到这一点，伙计们，我的脸埋在他的胸口，这样你们才能看到我的脚。你当时是不是快窒息了？有点。我在想，你是怎么呼吸的？雷恩也做着那种痛苦的平板支撑动作。为了不压死你？
So he didn't crush me so I could breathe. And then I was like, how do I wrap my feet around his calf? It's kind of awkward. You know why? Your ankles don't bend that way. Your shins don't bend that way. So I was doing this weird on action. Rain would roll over on top of me,
为了不压死我，所以我能呼吸。然后我当时想，我怎么把脚缠在他的小腿上？这有点尴尬。你知道为什么吗？你的脚踝不是那样弯曲的。你的小腿不是那样弯曲的。所以我做了这个奇怪的动作。雷恩会翻身压在我身上，
do his weird plank move. And one take, it kind of took a long time. He started to shake a little. Oh dear. All I will say is Rain, you're a very strong guy, but planking for him does take a toll on people. Take after take. We did a bunch of takes. Also, my feet were like in this weird position.
做他那奇怪的平板支撑动作。有一次拍摄，花的时间有点长。他开始有点发抖。天哪。我只想说，雷恩，你是个非常强壮的人，但对他来说，平板支撑确实让人吃不消。一次又一次。我们拍了很多次。而且，我的脚处于那种奇怪的位置。
So we did this every take and in between takes, we would roll on our backs side by side. We would have these really deep conversations. It was just one of those surreal moments where we were doing the most ridiculously silly thing. And then in between we talked about like our lives. I feel like this is the moment where I really became friends with rain because we talked about where we grew up and our childhoods and like what we believed in and just really had this really huge heart to heart in between this plank straddle foot rubbing of the
所以我们每次拍摄都这样做，在拍摄间隙，我们会并排躺在背上。我们会进行非常深入的交谈。那真是一个超现实的时刻，我们做着最荒谬可笑的事情。而在间隙，我们谈论着各自的生活。我觉得这就是我和Rain真正成为朋友的时刻，因为我们谈论了各自的成长经历、童年、信仰，并在那次平板支撑跨步揉脚的间隙，进行了一次非常深刻的交心。
calf. I did write about this in my journal as well. Okay. And I just said that I was really glad they weren't rolling sound out there. We weren't mic'd because I was giggling so much whenever we had to rub beat. Aw. So that kind of is the end of the episode. That ends the episode. There's a little tag where we go back to the improv class. It's a little bit of a flashback. I think that they just loved this monologue, this talking head that Steve gives so much that they had to include it at the end of the episode. But I don't know if you remember this, Angela, that last night when we shot, we stayed till after midnight. It was a really late night. And I also wrote this in my journal. I said, Steve ordered pizzas for the cast and crew. And we all had like a little, a little bitty like kind of,
小腿。我也在日记里写过这件事。好的。我只是说我很高兴当时没有录音。我们没有戴麦克风，因为每次要揉脚时我都会笑个不停。噢。那差不多就是这一集的结尾了。那一集就到此结束。有一个小片段，我们回到了即兴表演课。那是一个小小的闪回。我想他们太喜欢史蒂夫给出的这段独白，这段访谈了，所以他们必须把它放在这一集的结尾。但我不知道你是否还记得，安吉拉，拍摄的最后一晚，我们一直待到午夜之后。那是一个非常晚的夜晚。我也在日记里写了。我说，史蒂夫为演职人员点了披萨。我们都吃了一点点，就像那种，
I guess, mini party after the party. He ordered Barone's pizza. Yeah, his favorite. His favorite. It was so good. And that was that was really cool. I love that we kept journals. We. Women in our 30s journaling. We were 80 when we were 30. We're almost to our appropriate age. I think so.
我想，派对后的迷你派对。他点了Barone披萨。是的，他的最爱。他的最爱。真的很好吃。那真的很棒。我喜欢我们坚持写日记。我们。三十多岁的女性在写日记。我们三十岁时就像八十岁一样。我们快要达到我们应有的年龄了。我想是这样。
All right, guys, thank you so much. We cannot wait. Next week is the Christmas episode, the first Christmas episode, and we have a lot to say. Yankee swap. Thank you so much, Ken Jeong. Joel McHale, not so much. And we'll a lot to say. Yanky swap! Thank you so much Ken Jeong, Joel McHale not so much, and we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially
好了，伙计们，非常感谢。我们迫不及待了。下周是圣诞特辑，第一集圣诞特辑，我们有很多话要说。洋基交换礼物。非常感谢肯·郑。乔尔·麦克哈尔，没那么感谢。我们有很多话要说。洋基交换礼物！非常感谢肯·郑，乔尔·麦克哈尔没那么感谢，我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是
created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. It's the sweetest time of the year.
与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是凯西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这是一年中最甜蜜的时光。
Valentine's Day is approaching and Macy's has the best of the best gifts for your loved ones. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Here's what I love about Macy's. It really has a little something for everyone. This Valentine's Day I got my husband the most romantic gift ever. I got him a set of Tupperware, but hear me out. He really loves having nice Tupperware. He bakes a lot. He is a baker and a chef and I went to Macy's home section and they had amazing Tupperware so I got him a set
情人节即将来临，梅西百货为您所爱的人准备了最好的礼物。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为您的送礼指南。这就是我喜欢梅西百货的原因。它真的为每个人准备了一些东西。这个情人节，我给丈夫买了有史以来最浪漫的礼物。我给他买了一套特百惠，但听我说完。他真的很喜欢用好的特百惠。他经常烘焙。他是一位烘焙师和厨师，我去了梅西百货的家居区，他们有很棒的特百惠，所以我给他买了一套
of that and then while I was there I also got him a new skillet. He's gonna be so happy. And Josh I know you listen to the podcast so sorry. Now you know. But you know Macy's truly has everything you need at such great price points. Shop Macy's gift guides for the perfect hand-picked items for everyone on your list. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop in-store or online at macy's.com slash gift guide. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个，然后当我在那里的时候，我还给他买了一个新煎锅。他会非常高兴的。乔什，我知道你在听这个播客，所以抱歉。现在你知道了。但你知道梅西百货确实以如此优惠的价格拥有你需要的一切。选购梅西百货的礼品指南，为您名单上的每个人挑选完美的精选商品。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为您的送礼指南。在店内或在线访问macys.com/giftguide选购。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。